FACING FINANCIAL HARDSHIP DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC.
When we started
our business
we were paying an arm
and a leg for postage.
I remember setting up
ShipStation.
One or two clicks
and everything was
up and running.
I was printing out labels
and saving money.
ShipStation saves
us so much time.
It makes it really
easy and seamless.
Pick an order,
print everything
you need,
slap the label
onto the box,
and it's ready
to go.
Our costs for shipping
were cut in half.
Just like that.
ShipStation.
The #1 choice
of online sellers.
Go to ShipStation.com/try
and get 2 months free.
WE'RE MANNING THE HOSPITALS
BECAUSE STATES ARE, IN MANY
CASES, UNABLE TO GET ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE TO WORK.
IT'S JUST AN INCREDIBLE
SITUATION.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT ISSUES IN
BATTLING THIS PANDEMIC IS
COORDINATING THE SUPPLIES
THROUGHOUT THE NATION BASED UPON
THE MOST ACCURATE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE, AND WE'VE GOT THE
BEST HEALTH CARE AND DISASTER
EXPERTS ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD,
AND EVERYBODY WILL TELL YOU
THAT, AND WE'RE DEALING WITH BIG
PARTS OF THE WORLD ON HELPING
THEM ALSO THROUGH THIS HORRIBLE
SITUATION WHERE 151, STILL 151
NATIONS ARE GOING THROUGH IT.
WE'RE WORKING TO INSURE THAT THE
SUPPLIES ARE DELIVERED WHERE AND
WHEN THEY'RE NEEDED.
IN SOME CASES WE'RE TELLING
GOVERNORS WE CAN'T GO THERE
BECAUSE WE DON'T THINK YOU NEED
IT, AND WE THINK SOMEPLACE ELSE
NEEDS IT.
AND PRETTY MUCH SO FAR WE'VE
BEEN RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
AND WE'LL CONTINUE TO DO IT AS
IT REALLY GETS -- THIS WILL BE
PROBABLY THE TOUGHEST WEEK,
BETWEEN THIS WEEK AND NEXT WEEK,
AND THERE'LL BE A LOT OF DEATHS,
UNFORTUNATELY, BUT A LOT OF LESS
DEATH THAN IF THIS WASN'T DONE.
BUT THERE WILL BE DEATH.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR AN OBVIOUS
FOCUS IN THE HARDEST-HIT
REGIONS.
SOME OF THEM ARE OBVIOUS AND
SOME AREN'T SO OBVIOUS.
THEY SPRING UP.
THEY COME, AND THEY HIT YOU LIKE
YOU GOT HIT BY A CLUB.
AN AREA THAT WASN'T AT ALL
BOTHERED, YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN NEW JERSEY.
THE GOVERNOR'S DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB, BY THE WAY, BUT
HOW THAT SPRANG UP.
EVERY DECISION THAT WE'RE MAKING
IS MADE THE SAVE LIVES.
IT'S REALLY OUR SOLE
CONSIDERATION.
WE WANT TO SAVE LIVES.
WE WANT AS FEW LIVES LOST AS
POSSIBLE.
IT'S, THEREFORE, CRITICAL THAT
CERTAIN MEDIA OUTLETS STOP
SPREADING FALSE RUMORS AND
CREATING FEAR AND EVEN PANIC
WITH THE PUBLIC.
IT'S JUST INE CREDDING.
I COULD -- CAN INCREDIBLE, I
COULD NAME THEM, BUT IT'S THE
SAME ONES.
I GUESS THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
RATINGS, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR.
IT'S SO BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND IT, YOU LOOK
AT THE APPROVAL RATINGS, AND
THEY'RE THE LOWEST THEY'VE EVER
BEEN FOR MEDIA.
SOD BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY, SO BAD
FOR THE WORLD.
THEY'VE GOT TO PUT IT TOGETHER
FOR A LITTLE WHILE.
GET THIS OVER WITH AND THEN GO
BACK TO YOUR FAKE NEWS.
IT'S JUST ESSENTIAL THAT THE
FEDERAL DECISION MAKERS CUT
THROUGH THE FOG AND THE
CONFUSION IN ORDER TO FOLLOW THE
FACTS AND THE SCIENCE.
MANY HOSPITAL ADMINISTRATORS
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH
EVEN IN THE REALLY HOT SPOTS,
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE, ARE
COMMUNICATING DIRECTLY WITH US
THAT THEIR LEVELS OF SUPPLIES
ARE MEETING ESSENTIAL NEEDS.
AT THE CURRENT TIME, THEY'RE
REALLY THRILLED TO BE WHERE THEY
ARE.
WHENEVER LOCAL SHORTAGES ARE
REPORTED, WE'RE ASKING
STATEMENTS TO IMMEDIATELY MEET
THE DEMAND, AND WE'RE
STOCKPILING LARGE AMOUNTS IN
DIFFERENT AREAS, IN DIFFERENT
AREAS, AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
DISCUSSING THAT IN A LITTLE
WHILE.
BUT WE WANT DISTRIBUTIONS TO BE
MADE ON A FAIR BASIS.
WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF A LARGE
COUNTRY, NOT JUST CERTAIN AREAS
OF THE COUNTRY.
NO MATTER WHERE WE'RE -- WE'VE
BEEN THERE, AND WE'VE BEEN THERE
VERY STRONG.
I WANT TO THANK FEMA, I WANT TO
THANK THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS, I WANT TO THANK OUR
MILITARY FOR WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE ADDING A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF MILITARY TO
HELP SUPPLEMENT THE STATES.
THOUSANDS OF SOLDIERS, THOUSANDS
OF MEDICAL WORKERS,
PROFESSIONALS, NURSES, DOCTORS.
AND IT'LL BE A LARGE NUMBER.
IT'LL BE, WE'LL BE TELLING THEM
OVER THE NEXT VERY SHORT PERIOD
WHERE THEY'RE GOING.
THEY'RE GOING INTO WAR.
THEY'RE GOING INTO A BATTLE THAT
THEY'VE NEVER REALLY TRAIN THED
FOR.
NOBODY'S TRAINED FOR THIS,
NOBODY'S SEEN THIS I WOULD SAY
SINCE 1917 WHICH WAS THE
GREATEST OF THEM ALL.
THE GREAT OF THIS TYPE OF
BATTLE, PROBABLY THE GREATEST OF
THEM ALL, RIGHT?
1917.
UP TO 100 MILLION PEOPLE WERE
KILLED.
IN ADDITION, WE'RE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH HOSPITALS AND
EXISTING SUPPLIERS AND
DISTRIBUTERS TO INSURE THAT
THOSE WITH THE GREATEST NEED ARE
PRIORITIZED.
AND AND THAT NEED CHANGES.
ONE DAY IT'S ONE STATE OR ONE
LOCALE, ONE CITY, AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN THEY'RE STARTING TO
DO WELL.
WE HAD SOME VERY GOOD REPORTS
COMING OUT OF THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON, COMING OUT OF
VARIOUS PARTS OF CALIFORNIA.
SO AREAS THAT WE WERE GETTING
READY TO REALLY HIT HARD, WE CAN
NOW GO TO OTHER AREAS.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE NEW YORK IS
GOING TO BE HIT VERY HARD.
AND LOUISIANA IS JUST AMAZING
THE WAY IT JUST SPREAD OUT.
EVERYONE'S DOING A GOOD JOB, BUT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HIT HARD.
AREAS IN THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
NOT EXPERIENCING LARGE SCALE
INFECTIONS ARE REQUESTING
SUPPLIES BEYOND WHAT THEIR
PRESENT CIRCUMSTANCES REQUIRE,
AND WE TALK TO THEM AND WE TELL
THEM AND WE EXPLAN IF IT.
FOR THE MOST PART, THEY'RE GOOD
WITH IT.
WE THINK WE'RE RIGHT.
IT'S VERY UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
OFFICIALS WOULD SEEK TO GET THE
MOST THEY CAN GET FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT THE FEARS OF THE SHORTAGES
HAVE LED TO INFLATED REQUESTS.
WE HAVE SOME STATES AND AREAS
WHERE THEY'RE JUST ASKING FOR
FAR MORE -- LOOK, WE HAD ONE
STATE ASKING FOR 40,000
VENTILATORS.
40,000.
THINK OF IT, 40,000.
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE.
THEY WON'T NEED THAT MANY, AND
NOW THEY'RE ADMITTING THEY DON'T
NEED THAT MANY, BUT WE'RE
GETTING AS MANY AS WE CAN TO
THEM.
AGAIN, NOBODY'S EVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN TERMS OF
VENTILATORS, IN TERMS OF
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND GROUP
FORMS AND OUTFITS.
BUT IT MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT
FOR DISTRIBUTERS TO PRIORITIZE
THE REAL NEED, AND IT COULD
INTENTIONALLY AND, YOU KNOW,
THEY -- EVERYBODY HASP PROPER
INTENTIONS -- HAS PROPER
INTENTIONS, BUT THEY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE 100%.
AND SOMETIMES WHEN THEY KNOW
THEY DON'T NEED IT, THEY WANT IT
ANYWAY.
IT GIVES THEM THAT EXTRA FEELING
OF SATISFACTION, BUT WE JUST
CAN'T DO THAT.
IT'S NOT EVEN POSSIBLE TO THINK
ABOUT.
AND THAT'S WHY -- AND WE'RE
BACKUP.
REMEMBER, WE'RE A BACKUP.
WE'RE THE GREATEST BACKUP THAT
EVER EXISTED FOR THE STATES.
ESPECIALLY END WHEN WE START
GETTING INTO THE
HOSPITAL-BUILDING BUSINESS AND
GETTING INTO THE MEDICAL
CENTER-BUILDING BUSINESS.
WHEN YOU SEE WE BUILT MANY
HOSPITALS, NUMEROUS HOSPITALS IN
SOME STATES AND MEDICAL CENTERS.
THAT'S WHY MY ADMINISTRATION'S
BEEN REQUESTING ACTUAL USAGE
NUMBERS DIRECTLY FROM THE STATES
AND HOSPITALS TO MEET THEIR
NEEDS, BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE
READY WHEN THE BRUNT OF IT
COMES, WHICH IS COMING QUICKLY,
YOU SEE IT, YOU SEE IT AS SURE
AS YOU CAN SEE IT.
AND WHEN THE BRUNT OF IT COMES,
WE WANT TO BE READY TO HIT THE
AREA THAT NEEDS IT.
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE SPENT
EVERYTHING IN ONE AREA AND THEY
DON'T NEED IT THERE TO ANYWHERE
NEAR THE EXTENT.
SO LET ME BE EXTREMELY CLEAR
ABOUT ONE POINT, WE WILL MOVE
HEAVEN AND EVERETT TO
SAFEGUARD -- AND EARTH TO
SAFEGUARD OUR GREAT AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO USE WITH
EVERY POWER, EVERY AUTHORITY,
EVERY SINGLE RESOURCE WE'VE GOT
TO KEEP OUR PEOPLE HEALTHY,
SAFE, SECURE AND TO GET THIS
THING OVER WITH.
WE WANT TO FINISH THIS WAR.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO WORK.
WE HAVE TO GET -- WE HAVE TO
OPEN OUR COUNTRY AGAIN.
WE HAVE TO OPEN OUR COUNTRY
AGAIN.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE DOING THIS
FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS.
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN OUR COUNTRY
AGAIN.
THIS COUNTRY WASN'T MEANT FOR
THIS.
FEW WERE.
BUT WE HAVE TO OPEN OUR COUNTRY
AGAIN.
I JUST SPOKE WITH THE
COMMISSIONERS, LEADERS OF I
WOULD SAY VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE
SPORTS LEAGUES.
ROB MANFRED, COMMISSIONER OF
BASEBALL, ROGER GOODELL,
COMMISSIONER OF THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE.
ADAM SILVER, COMMISSIONER OF THE
NATIONAL BASKETBALL ASSOCIATION.
GARY BECKMAN, COMMISSIONER OF
THE NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE.
JAY MONAGHAN, COMMISSIONER OF
THE PGA TOUR.
KATHY ENGELBERT, COMMISSIONER OF
THE WOMEN'S NATIONAL BASKETBALL
ASSOCIATION.
DANA WHITE, THE ULTIMATE
FIGHTING CHAMPIONSHIP.
VINCE McMAHON, PRESIDENT OF
THE WWE.
DON GARBER, COMMISSIONER OF
MAJOR LEAGUE SOCCER.
STEVE PHELPS, PRESIDENT OF
NASCAR.
MICHAEL WAND, COMMISSIONER OF
THE LPGA.
ROGER PENSKE, FOUNDER AND
CHAIRMAN, PENSKE CORP..
AND DREW FELLOWING, PRESIDENT OF
THE BREEDERS -- FLEMING.
PRESIDENT OF THE BREEDERS CUP.
AND THERE WERE A COUPLE OF
OTHERS ON.
THESE ARE ALL THE GREAT LEADERS
OF SPORT, AND THEY WANT TO GET
BACK, THEY'VE GOT TO GET BACK.
THEY CAN'T DO THIS.
THE SPORTS WEREN'T DESIGNED FOR
IT.
THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF OUR NATION
WASN'T DESIGNED FOR IT.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK.
WE WANT TO GET BACK SOON, VERY
SOON.
FOR EXAMPLE, AND I HAVE TO SAY
WE'RE USING THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT VERY POWERFULLY
AND SOMETIMES DIRECTLY, IN MANY
CASES INDIRECTLY.
JUST THE THREAT OF IT'S USUALLY
ENOUGH.
BUT FEMA AND HHS HAVE ORDERED
180 MILLION -- THINK OF THAT,
180 MILLION, WHOEVER HEARD OF
180 MILLION N-95 MASKS?
AND WE'RE WORKING NOW WITH 3M TO
SEE WHETHER OR NOT THAT ALL
WORKS OUT.
BUT WE WANT THEM TO HELP OUR
COUNTRY.
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO SOON LET YOU
KNOW.
BUT WE NEED THE MASKS.
WE DON'T WANT OTHER PEOPLE
GETTING THEM.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE, THAT'S WHY
WE'RE INSTITUTING A LOT OF
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT.
YOU COULD CALL IT REALUATIONS,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT IS, IT'S
A RETALIATION.
IF PEOPLE DON'T, IF PEOPLE DON'T
GIVE US WHAT WE NEED FOR OUR
PEOPLE, WE'RE GOING TO BE VERY
TOUGH, AND WE'VE BEEN VERY
TOUGH.
USUALLY WE DON'T HAVE TO USE IT,
BUT WE'VE USED IT PLENTY.
IT'S TURNING OUT MORE AND MORE,
UNFORTUNATELY.
AND IT WORKS VERY WELL.
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN LOGISTICS TASK
FORCE LED BY BY THE ADMIRAL
WHO'S DOING A FANTASTIC JOB WILL
INSURE THEY'RE DISTRIBUTED TO
THE HEALTH CARE AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKERS IN THE
AREA WITH THE MOST PRESSING
REQUIREMENTS.
THAT'S THE 6 OF -- 60 MILLION
MAXES THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
AND THE 180 MILLION N-95 MASKS.
180 MILLION, WHO EVER HEARD OF
180 MILLION MASKS?
AND THIS IS A INCREDIBLE THINGS.
A LOT OF TIMES, AND WE HAVE TO
STOP PLAYING THIS GUAM, IF A
ABOVE WANTS 200 VENTILATORS AND
I SAY, NO, WE'RE GOING TO SEND
YOU 1,000, WE THINK YOU NEED
MORE THAN 200.
AND THEN THE MEDIA MEETS WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND THEY SAY, OH,
YOU GOT MORE?
WELL, IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD HAVE SENT
MORE.
SO HE'S ASKING FOR 200, WE GIVE
HIM 1,000.
THEY SAY HOW'S THE PRESIDENT
DOING?
HE SHOULD HAVE GIVEN MORE.
BECAUSE THAT'S POLITICS.
THAT'S POLITICS.
AND THAT'S UNFORTUNATE, BECAUSE
WE CAN'T PLAY THAT GAME.
AND, YOU KNOW, THAT'S ONE PARTY
DOING IT, AND THE OTHER PARTY'S
HAPPY.
BUT THEY'RE ALL REALLY HAPPY
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DOING THIS WORK THEMSELVES FOR A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
MANY OF THEIR CUPBOARDS WERE
BARE.
FEMA AND HHS CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THE DATA ON AN HOURLY BASIS
WE'RE PROVIDED BY THE STATES IN
ORDER TO MOST EFFECTIVELY TARGET
THE DISTRIBUTION OF SUPPLIES.
WE'VE BEEN ASKING STATES TO
PROVIDE US WITH DAILY UPDATES ON
THE NUMBER OF VENTILATORS AND
THEIR UTILIZATION RATES.
BECAUSE SOME STATES HAVE MORE
VENTILATORS THAN THEY NEED.
THEY DON'T EVEN LIKE TO ADMIT
IT.
THEY'LL ADMIT IT WHEN
EVERYTHING'S OVER, BUT THAT
DOESN'T HELP US VERY MUCH.
THIS DATA IS VITALLY NECESSARY
SO THAT WE CAN INSURE
VENTILATORS ARE GETTING TO THE
RIGHT PLACE AT THE RIGHT TIME.
FEMA, HHS, DoD ARE DEVELOPING
RESOURCES WITHIN THE NEXT 24
HOURS, THEY WILL HAVE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT SET OF CRITERIA.
EVERY DAY IT'S DIFFERENT
CRITERIA.
EVERY DAY THIS HORRIBLE
INVISIBLE ENEMY CHANGES THE
COURSE.
IT CHANGES COURSE.
IF YOU WERE FIGHTING THE NORMAL
FIGHT, YOU'D KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
HERE'S -- THEY HIT ONE, THEY HIT
ANOTHER, THEY HIT ANOTHER STATE.
THEY HIT AREAS THAT YOU DIDN'T
EXPECT.
BUT WE'RE WATCHING IT, AND WE'RE
CAPTURING IT.
OUR GOAL IS TO STAY SEVERAL DAYS
AHEAD OF THE NEEDS IN EACH
STATE, BUT WE CAN ONLY DO THAT
IF THE CITIES AND STATES UTILIZE
REALTIME LOCAL KNOWLEDGE TO
PROVIDE TIMELY AND PRECISE DATA
ABOUT ACTUAL USAGE.
SO WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
AND IF A STATE HAS VENTILATORS,
AS AN EXAMPLE, THAT THEY KNOW
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO NEED, THEY
SHOULD GIVE THEM OVER, AND WE
SHOULD MOVE THEM WITH THE OTHER
ONES.
WE HAVE NOW 10,000 IN OUR
PIPELINE, STOCK FUEL.
10 -- STOCK FUEL.
10,000 PLUS.
AND WE'RE MOVING SOME INTO NEW
YORK.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL.
WE'RE MOVING SOME INTO NEW YORK
CITY AND STATE SEPARATELY, AND
WE'RE BRINGING THEM TO THE POINT
WHERE THEY'LL NEED THEM.
I CAN ALSO REPORT THAT AT MY
DIRECTION 1,000 MILITARY
PERSONNEL ARE DEPLOWING TO NEW
YORK CITY TO -- DEPLOYING TO NEW
YORK CITY TO ASSIST WHERE
THEY'RE NEEDED THE MOST.
THAT'S THE HOTTEST OF ALL THE
HOT SPOTS.
NEW JERSEY'S RIGHT THERE, IT'S
RIGHT NEXT TO IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S OVERFLOW,
BUT NEW JERSEY'S -- IT'S A GREAT
STATE, AND IT'S A VERY, IT'S A
CROWDED STATE ALSO WHERE YOU
HAVE PEOPLE ON TOP OF PEOPLE
IT'S ALWAYS TOUGH.
BUT WE'RE BRINGING SOME OF THE
VENTILATORS.
WE GOT SOME FOR NEW JERSEY JUST
YESTERDAY, AND WE'RE GOING TO
BRING THEM SOME MORE INCLUDING
DOCTORS.
WE'RE GETTING DOCTORS, NURSES,
RESPIRATORY SPECIALISTS AND
OTHER SUPPORT WORKERS -- THESE
ARE FROM THE MILITARY.
WE'RE TAKING PEOPLE NOW OUT OF
OUR MILITARY.
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT, BUT NOW
WE'RE DOING IT ON A LARGER
BASIS.
AND I WANT TO THANK SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE ESPER WHO WILL DETAIL
SOME OF WHAT WE'RE DOING
TOMORROW AND MONDAY.
AS THE SITUATION IN WASHINGTON
STATE CONTINUES TO STABILIZE,
WE'RE RETURNING A 300-BED
FEDERAL MEDICAL STATION TO A
DIFFERENT LOCATION WHERE WE NEED
IT, AND WE APPRECIATE THAT.
THEY WON'T BE NEEDING IT, AND IF
WE APPRECIATE THEM LETTING US
KNOW.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE IT TO A
DIFFERENT LOCATION.
IT WAS ALREADY BULLET.
MANY GOVERNORS -- BUILT.
MANY GOVERNORS INITIALLY MADE
LARGE REQUESTS FOR FEDERAL
SUPPORT FOR THEIR STATES IN
ANTICIPATION OF A GREATER NUMBER
OF CASES, BUT THE RESIDENTS OF
WASHINGTON STATE HAVE DONE A
REALLY GOOD JOB OF FOLLOWING THE
FEDERAL DISTANCING GUIDELINES.
THEY REALLY HAVE.
I'M ALSO PLEASED TO REPORT THAT
OREGON WILL BE SPENDING AND
SENDING -- THEY'RE SPENDING A
LOT OF MONEY BECAUSE THEY REALLY
DID STOCKPILE WELL, AND THEY'RE
ALSO SENDING 140 VENTILATORS
DIRECTLY TO NEW YORK, WHICH WE
APPRECIATE.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE GREAT WORK
HE'S DOING EVERY DAY DEALING
WITH OUR NATION'S GOVERNORS.
MIKE PENCE HAS BEEN WORKING DAY
AND NIGHT ON THIS, AND WE WANT
TO GET IT OVER.
HE'S GOT TO GET A LITTLE MORE
SLEEP THAN HE'S GETTING.
HE HASN'T BEEN GETTING VERY
MUCH, I WILL TELL YOU THAT.
AND WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER,
AND IT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING TO
SEE HOW PEOPLE ARE JOINING
FORCES TO HELP ONE ANOTHER.
THEY REALLY ARE.
IN ADDITION TO OUR COURAGEOUS
DOCTORS, NURSES AND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, I ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE INCREDIBLE FOOD SUPPLY
WORKERS WHO ARE FEEDING OUR
NATION.
I SPOKE JUST A LITTLE WHILE AGO
TO SENATOR BOZEMAN, YOU KNOW
SENATOR BOOZMAN, WE ALL DO.
HE'S A GREAT SENATOR, A GREAT
PERSON.
WE SPOKE JUST THIS MORNING, AND
WE DISCUSSED HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO KEEP OUR FARMERS AND
RANCHERS, PROCESSERS AND
DISTRIBUTERS IN OUR NATION'S
PRAYERS.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR THE INCREDIBLE JOB HE'S BEEN
DOING.
AND A LOT OF THE SENATORS AND
CONGRESSMEN AND EVERYONE,
EVERYBODY'S WORKING VERY HARD.
MY ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
VERY AGGRESSIVELY TO PIONEER NEW
MEDICAL COUNTERMEASURES TO TREAT
AND PREVENT INFECTION, WORKING
ON A LOT OF THINGS.
WE MUST UTILIZE OUR NATION'S
SCIENTIFIC BRILLIANCE TO
VANQUISH THE VIRUS.
WE HAVE TO VANQUISH THE VIRUS AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING IN THIS COUNTRY, AND
WE HAVE A GREAT FUTURE, BUT WE
HAVE TO GET BACK TO WORK.
THIS WEEK THE FDA ESTABLISHED
THE CORONAVIRUS TREATMENT
ACCELERATOR PROGRAM WHICH IS
EXPEDITING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW ANTIVIRAL AND AND OTHER
THERAPIES, AND THEY'RE DOING IT
ON A VERY RAPID BASIS S. AND I
THINK WE'RE HAVING SOME VERY
GOOD RESULTS.
WE'LL TELL YOU ABOUT THAT.
HHS CONTINUES TO SPEED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THERAPIES DERIVED
FROM HUMAN BLOOD THAT HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO LESSEN THE SEVERITY
OR SHORTEN THE LENGTH OF THE
ILLNESS.
AND AS YOU KNOW, LAST SATURDAY
THE FDA ALSO GAVE EMERGENCY
AUTHORIZATION FOR
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, AND THE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS -- I HOPE
IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT ANSWER.
WE'RE HAVING SOME VERY GOOD
THINGS HAPPENING WITH IT, AND
WE'RE GOING TO BE CONTRIBUTING
IT THROUGH -- DISTRIBUTING IT
THROUGH THE STRATEGIC NATIONAL
STOCKPILE.
IT'S GOING INTO THE STRATEGIC
NATIONAL STOCKPILE TO TREAT
CERTAIN PATIENTS, AND WE HAVE
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF DOSES
OF IT.
29 MILLION, TO BE EXACT.
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE'RE MAKING
IT, AND WE'RE ALSO GETTING FROM
VARIOUS OTHER LOCATIONS AND
COUNTRIES.
IN ONE CASE I CALLED PRIME
MINISTER MODI OF INDIA THIS
MORNING.
THEY MAKE LARGE AMOUNTS OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, VERY LARGE
AMOUNTS, FRANKLY.
AND I SAID -- THEY HAD A HOLD
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE 1.5
BILLION PEOPLE.
THEY THINK A LOT OF IT, AND I
SAID I'D APPRECIATE IF THEY
WOULD RELEASE THE AMOUNTS THAT
WE ORDERED, AND THEY ARE GIVING
IT SERIOUS CONSIDERATION.
BUT THEY DO MAKE -- INDIA MAKES
A LOT OF IT.
BUT WE HAVE ALREADY 29 MILLION,
IF YOU LOOK, THAT'S A BIG
NUMBER, 29 MILLION DOSES.
WE'VE GOT MILLIONS OF DOSES THAT
ARE BEING MADE HERE AND MANY
MILLIONS OF DOSES THAT ARE MADE
ELSEWHERE THAT ARE BEING SHIPPED
HERE AND WILL BE ARRIVING.
WE ARE JUST WITH HEARING REALLY
POSITIVE STORIES, AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO COLLECT THE DATA.
BUT I'LL JUST SPEAK FOR MOUSSE,
IT'S BEEN OUT -- FOR MYSELF.
IT'S BEEN OUT FOR A LONG TIME.
IT'S A MALARIA TRUCK.
IT'S ALSO A DRUG -- IT'S A
MALARIA DRUG.
IT'S ALSO A DRUG FOR LUPUS.
AND THERE'S A STUDY OUT THAT
PEOPLE WITH LUPUS ARE NOT
CATCHING THIS HORRIBLE VIRUS.
THEY'RE NOT AFFECTED SO MUCH BY
IT.
NOW MAYBE THAT'S CORRECT, MAYBE
IT'S FALSE.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO CHECK IT
OUT.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF VERY
POSITIVE THINGS HAPPENING WITH
THAT.
THAT'S A GAME-CHANGER, IF THAT'S
THE CASE.
OBVIOUSLY, WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THE VACCINES, BUT THE
VACCINES HAVE TO BE DOWN THE
ROAD BY PROBABLY 14, 15, 16
MONTHS.
WE'RE DOING GREAT ON THE
VACCINES.
I THINK JOHNSON & JOHNSON IS
LEADING, SEEMS TO BE LEADING IN
TERMS OF THE STUDIES, BUT WE'LL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THAT, BUT
THAT'S DOWN THE ROAD.
BUT TREMENDOUS PROMISE WITH
WHAT'S JUST BEEN MENTIONED.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, GILEAD
SCIENCES HAS INITIATED A PHASE
THREE -- DOWN THE LINE,
MEANING -- CLINICAL STUDIES OF
THE DRUG REM DECEMBER MERE.
IT'S APPROXIMATELY 1,000
PATIENTS WHICH IS A PRETTY GOOD
STUDY.
OTHER DRUGS ARE ALSO BEING
STUDIED IN PATIENTS, AND THIS
WEEK ORACLE -- GREAT COMPANY --
DONATED A NEW WEB PORTAL.
LARRY ELLISON, AMAZING GUY.
AND PLATFORM TO THE GOVERNMENT
TO GATHER REALTIME DATA ON HOW
PATIENTS ARE RESPONDING TO THE
VARIOUS NEW TREATMENTS.
AND THEY HAVE A VERY
SOPHISTICATED SITE, AND WE'LL BE
LEARNING A LOT FROM ORACLE.
THANK YOU TO THEM.
WE'RE ALSO SPENDING ECONOMIC
DOLLARS LIKE YOU WOULDN'T
BELIEVE AND SPEEDING ECONOMIC
RELIEF TO AMERICAN WORKERS,
FAMILIES AND BUSINESSES.
YESTERDAY THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION LAUNCHED THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM TO
HELP EMPLOYEES -- EMPLOYERS KEEP
PAYING THEIR WORKERS.
IN 24 HOURS THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION AND OVER 1,200
LENDING PARTNERS PROCESSED OVER
28,000 LOANS.
IT'S SO FAR AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
AND BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
IT'S WORKED OUT INCREDIBLY WELL,
AND I WANT TO THANK BANK OF
AMERICA AND JPMORGAN CHASE AND A
LOT OF THE BIG BANKS THAT HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED AND A LOT OF THE
COMMUNITY BANKS.
COMMUNITY BANKS HAVE REALLY
JUMPED ON IT, AND IT'S SO FAR
GOING WAY AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
THE SBA ALSO CLARIFIED THAT
FAITH-BASED ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING HOUSES OF WORSHIP ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM.
THAT'S GREAT.
AS WELL AS THE ECONOMIC INJURY
DISASTER LOAN PROGRAM THAT
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH.
ON THE SAME TERMS AS EVERY OTHER
APPLICANT.
IF WE RUN OUT OF FUNDING FOR THE
EMPLOYEE RETENTION PROGRAM, I
WILL IMMEDIATELY ASK CONGRESS
FOR MORE MONEY.
THIS IS MONEY THAT'S REALLY
GOING DIRECTLY TO THE PEOPLE
THAT NEED IT, THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT NEED IT AND THE
WORKERS THAT NEED IT.
FINALLY, I CAN -- WHEN WE OPEN,
WE WANT TO OPEN STRONG WITH
BUSINESSES THAT ARE GOING.
REMEMBER, WE HAD THE GREAT
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD, AND THEN
ONE DAY WE WERE TOLD YOU'VE GOT
TO SHUT IT DOWN, STOP IT.
TELL EVERYONE TO STAY HOME
BECAUSE OF THIS HORRIBLE VIRUS.
AND WE DID THAT.
AND WE DID THE RIGHT THING.
BUT NOW WE HAVE TO OPEN.
WE HAVE TO OPEN OUR COUNTRY.
FINALLY, I CAN REPORT THAT AS OF
TODAY THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS
SUCCESSFULLY CONSIDERED
COORDINATED THE SAFE RUSH OF
MORE THAN 40,000 AMERICANS STUCK
ABROAD ON OVER 400 FLIGHTS FROM
75 COUNTRIES.
MANY OF THOSE COUNTRIES WERE
TERRIFIC IN HELPING US.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH.
SOME OF THEM I HAD TO CALL THE
LEADERS OF THE COUNTRY, MOST OF
WHOM I KNOW, AND ONCE I DID,
THEY SNAPPED LIKE YOU WOULDN'T
BELIEVE.
THEY REALLY HELPED US, SO I
APPRECIATE THAT.
SO WE BROUGHT BACK 40,000
AMERICANS WHO WERE LITERALLY
STUCK IN SOME COUNTRIES WITH NO
CHANCE OF GETTING OUT.
WE GOT 'EM BACK.
400 FLIGHTS, 75 COUNTRIES.
THINK OF THAT.
AND THOSE COUNTRIES IN ALMOST
EVERY INSTANCE HAD A BIG PROBLEM
WITH THE VIRUS.
I WANT TO THANK THE MESH PEOPLE
MOST OF ALL -- THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR THE SELFLESS
SACRIFICES THEY'RE MAKING FOR
OUR NATION.
I KNOW IT'S NOT PLEASANT, A
ALTHOUGH SOME PEOPLE HAVE SAID
THEY'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW THEIR
FAMILY BETTER, AND THEY LOVE
THEIR FAMILY MORE THAN EVER.
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING.
THEY'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN TO KNOW
'EM.
THEY'RE IN THE SAME HOUSE WITH
THEIR FAMILY FOR A LONG TIME.
I GUESS IT CAN ALSO WORK THE
OTHER WAY PERHAPS, BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
I WANT TO ENCOURAGE EVERYONE TO
KEEP FOLLOWING OUR GUIDELINES ON
SLOWING THE SPREAD.
SUSTAINING THIS WAR EFFORT IS --
AND THAT'S WHAT IT IS, THIS IS A
WAR EFFORT -- IS THE PATRIOTIC
DUTY OF EVERY CITIZEN.
WHILE WE MAY BE MORE PHYSICALLY
DISTANT FOR A TIME, WE'RE CLOSER
TOGETHER IN THE HEART AND IN THE
SPIRIT.
AND THROUGH THIS GREAT NATIONAL
UNITY -- IT'S HAPPENING.
WE'RE HAVING A GREAT UNITY
DEVELOPING THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
DIDN'T THINK WOULD BE POSSIBLE
TO DEVELOP LIKE THIS.
AND WE WILL CONQUER THE DISEASE
AND RESTORE OUR NATION TO ITS
FULL AND GLORIOUS MIGHT.
WE'RE DOING REALLY WELL, AND I'M
VERY PROUD OF EVERYBODY OUT
THERE.
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF YOU.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT NOBODY COULD
HAVE EVER PROJECTED.
IT'S BEEN OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
THAT A THING LIKE THIS HAS
HAPPENED.
AND THE PROBLEM WITH THIS ONE IS
IS THE CONTAGION.
IT'S SO CONTAGIOUS.
NOBODY'S EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT WHERE IT'S SO CONTAGIOUS.
YOU CAN BE JUST TALKING TO
SOMEBODY AND CATCH IT.
YOU CAN CATCH IT, YOU KNOW HOW
LONG IT CAN LIVE ON SURFACES.
SO THINGS THAT NOBODY EVEN
THOUGHT OF, THE LEVEL OF
CONTAGION.
SO WE'RE GETTING THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S OVER SOON.
AND JUST KEEP GOING.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE LONG AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT, I'D LIKE TO ASK
DR. HAN TO SPEAK, AND HE'S BEEN
DOING YEOMAN'S WORK AT THE FDA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, DOCTOR.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I'M GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND THE
EFFORTS AROUND THAT.
JUST TO PREFACE, I'D LIKE TO
ECHO WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
THE RESILIENCY E AND THE JUST
TERRIFIC WORK.
MITIGATION IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR FIGHT AGAINST THE
COVID-19 VIRUS.
LAST WEEK, AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID, WE ISSUED AN EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION TO ALLOW THE
DONATED HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE TO
COME INTO THE COUNTRY AND ENTER
THE GENERAL CIRCULATION.
WE ARE PRIORITIZING THIS DRUG TO
COME IN FOR CLINICAL TRIALS,
ALSO INTO GENERAL USE FOR
PHYSICIANS BECAUSE, AS YOU KNOW,
PHYSICIANS -- BASED UPON THEIR
INTERACTION WITH THE PATIENTS,
THEY ASSESSMENT OF THE RISKS AND
BENEFITS -- CAN WRITE A
PRESCRIPTION FOR
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IF THEY THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR THE
PATIENT.
BEING A PHYSICIAN, WE DO THIS
ALL THE TIME.
AND THAT ASSESSMENT NEEDS TO BE
DONE BETWEEN PATIENT AND A
DOCTOR.
AND THEN THE THIRD PORTION IS WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THESE DRUGS
WERE IN THE CIRCULATION, IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN SO THAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE THEM OR NEED THEM FOR THE
OTHER INDICATIONS -- LUPUS,
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS -- HAD THEM
AVAILABLE.
THAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF THE
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION.
ONE OTHER THING I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THAT WE, ON FRIDAY,
STOOD UP A FORMAL CONVALESCENT
PLASMA PROGRAM.
WE HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF
ENTHUSIASM FOR THAT.
THERE ARE SOME REPORTS THAT THIS
IS A BENEFIT TO PATIENTS IN
OTHER COUNTRIES WHO HAVE HAD
COVID-19 VIRUS.
AND WHAT THIS MEANS IS TAKING
PLASMA FROM PATIENTS WHO HAVE
HAD THE VIRUS AND WHO HAVE
RECOVERED AND TRANSFERRING THE
IMMUNITY FROM THAT PERSON TO
SOMEONE WHO'S SICK.
AND WE'RE, HOPEFULLY, EXPANDING
THAT ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE RED CROSS IS INVOLVED IN
THAT PROGRAM, AND I THINK IT
SHOWS GREAT PROMISE.
IT NEEDS TO BE STUDIED LIKE
OTHER THINGS, BUT JUST LIKE I
SAID BEFORE, PROVIDES HOPE.
WE DON'T WANT TO PROVIDE FALSE
HOPE BUT DEFINITELY HOPE.
THANK YOU.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I'D LIKE TO JUST TAKE A COUPLE
OF MOMENTS TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PUBLIC HEALTH ASPECTS
AND HOW IT RELATES TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT JUST SAID ABOUT THE
NEED FOR US TO BEGIN TO AT LEAST
THINK ABOUT RETURNING TO SOME
DEGREE OF NORMALITY.
AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH WHAT'S
GOING TO BE HAPPENING AS WE END
THIS WEEK AND WE GO INTO NEXT
WEEK.
YOU WILL BE SEEING -- AND WE
SHOULD NOT BE SURPRISED, BECAUSE
THE KINETICS OF HOW THIS VIRUS
WORKS -- IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE SEEING THAT THERE ARE GOING
TO BE DEATHS THAT ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GO UP.
BUT AS I MENTIONED TO THIS GROUP
AND TO THE GENERAL PUBLIC
MULTIPLE TIMES, THERE THE REALLY
IS A CASCADING OF EVENTS WHERE
YOU HAVE NEW CASES,
HOSPITALIZATIONS, INTENSIVE CARE
AND DEATHS.
SO AT THE SAME TIME THAT WE MAY
BE SEEING AN INCREASE IN DEATHS,
WE WANT TO FOCUS ON THE EFFECT
OF MITIGATION IS REALLY THE
NUMBER OF NEW CASES.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE THINKING ABOUT AND LOOKING
ABOUT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO PAY CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THAT AND,
HOPEFULLY, THE KINDS OF
MITIGATIONS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
IMPACT TO ALLOW US TO BEGIN TO
THINK ABOUT MAYBE CHANGING A
BIT.
SO THE QUESTION ARISES, IS THE
MITIGATIONORKING?
SO LET'S LOOK HISTORICALLY, AND
THEN JUST LOOK AT THE REALITY OF
IT.
CLEARLY IN THE COUNTRIES, CHINA
INCLUDED, THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
VERY STRICT KINDS OF PROGRAMS OF
MITIGATION, CLEARLY IT WORKS.
IN OUR OWN COUNTRY WE'VE SEEN
INDICATION OF THAT IN
WASHINGTON.
REMEMBER, WASHINGTON STATE WAS
THE FIRST TO GET HIT.
BUT THEY PUT IN A REALLY GOOD
PROGRAM OF MITIGATION.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE CHARTS
THAT DR. BIRX SHOWED THE OTHER
DAY, THEY'RE STILL DOWN THERE
DOING WELL.
AND THE REASON IS, AGAIN WHAT
I'VE SAID BEFORE BUT I THINK
IT'S WORTH REITERATING, THAT WE
HAVE TWO OPPOSING FORCES HERE.
THE VIRUS, WHICH THE VIRUS WANTS
TO DO WHAT THE VIRUS WANTS TO
DO, VIRUSES TRANSMIT FROM PEOPLE
TO PEOPLE.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE SEPARATED FROM
EACH OTHER, VIRUS DOES NOT
TRANSMIT.
IT DOESN'T GO ENOUGH.
AND THAT'S THE REASON WHY
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS THE
PHYSICAL SEPARATION -- BECAUSE
IF YOU LOOK AT THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S CHART THAT HE SHOWS
ALL THE TIME HERE FROM THIS
PODIUM, EVERY ASPECT OF THAT
ENDING THE COVID OUTBREAK IN 30
DAYS HAS SOME ASPECT OF PHYSICAL
SEPARATION.
WHETHER THAT'S AVOIDING CROWDS,
WHETHER THAT'S STAYING 6 FEET
AWAY FROM PEOPLE, WHETHER THAT'S
DOING TELEWORKING, ALL OF THIS
DOES THAT.
THAT'S OUR MOST IMPORTANT TOOL.
WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT VACCINES
AND DRUGS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT WE'LL MITIGATE LATER.
BUT THIS IS REALLY WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO.
AND I WANT TO ACTUALLY JUST
PLEAD, AS I DO MULTIPLE TIMES
FROM HERE, TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
YOU KNOW, AS SOBERING AND AS
DIFFICULT AS THIS IS, WHAT WE
ARE DOING IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO CONTINUE TO
DO THAT.
I MUST TELL YOU I WAS JUST
MENTIONING TO THE VICE PRESIDENT
AS WE CAME IN LAST NIGHT, WHEN I
WASN'T HERE, I WENT OUT WITH MY
WIFE AND ACTUALLY DID A LITTLE
POWER WALKING DOWN MASSACHUSETTS
AVENUE FOR THOSE TO WHO LIVE IN
WASHINGTON, KNOW WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
AND WE PASSED A COUPLE OF
RESTAURANTS WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING TAKEOUT FOOD.
THE RESTAURANTS WERE CLOSED TO
PEOPLE GOING IN, BUT THEY WERE
OPEN TO TAKEOUT.
AND I SAW SOMETHING THAT
ABSOLUTELY MADE ME FEEL REALLY,
REALLY GOOD.
THEY WERE SEPARATING THEMSELVES
BY AT LEAST 6 FEET.
IN FACT, SOME OF THE RESTAURANTS
HAD LITTLE THINGS ON THE FLOOR
THAT SAID STAND HERE, STAND
THERE, STAND THERE.
AND I THINK IF WE AS A NATION
PULL TOGETHER TO DO THAT,
HOPEFULLY WHEN WE KEEP COMING
BACK HERE AT THESE PRESS
CONFERENCES, WE'LL BE ABLE TO
SHOW YOU THAT THAT CURVE THAT WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT IS GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS LATER.
THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, PLEASE.
>> YOU SAID EARLIER THAT THE
VIRUS IS SPRINGING UP IN AREAS
YOU DID NOT EXPECT.
YESTERDAY YOU SAID SOME STATES
IN THE COUNTRY ARE NOT IN
JEOPARDY.
THE FACT THAT THIS IS
UNPREDICTABLE, ISN'T THAT AN
ARGUMENT FOR EVERY STATE TO HAVE
ONE --
>> LOOK, THERE ARE SOME STATES
THAT ARE, YOU HAVE GREAT
DISTANCE, NATURAL DISTANCE, BIG
LAND.
FEW PEOPLE.
AND THEY'RE IN VERY GOOD SHAPE.
AND IF THERE IS A CASE, THEY CAN
QUARANTINE THAT PERSON, OR THAT
PERSON WILL BE SEPARATED, WILL
BE BROUGHT TO A HOSPITAL, A
SECURE AREA.
SO YOU DO HAVE DIFFERENT CASES
AS OPPOSED TO A NEW YORK OR LOS
ANGELES.
LOS ANGELES IS DOING INCREDIBLY
WELL, BY THE WAY.
BUT AREAS WHERE YOU HAVE LOTS OF
PEOPLE TIGHT TOGETHER, IT'S A
BIG DIFFERENCE.
NO, THERE ARE DIFFERENT, THERE
ARE MANY DIFFERENT CASES.
PLEASE.
>> YOU MENTIONED MILITARY OFF
THE TOP, SO 1,000 TROOPS GOING
TO NEW YORK, AND THEN ARE WE
EXPECTING OTHER MASS
DEPLOYMENTS?
AND THEN IS IT JUST ARMY --
>> NO, NOT MASS -- MANY OF THE
PLACES ARE REALLY IN GREAT
SHAPE.
THEY REALLY HAVE DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB.
AND WE MAY ADD TO THE THOUSAND,
BUT NEW YORK WILL BE GETTING
ABOUT A THOUSAND MILITARY
PEOPLE, NURSES, DOCTORS, LOTS OF
OTHER PEOPLE, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT THEY NEED.
AND THAT'S -- MEDICAL.
NO, NO, MEDICAL MILITARY.
PLEASE.
>> YOU TWEETED EARLIER TODAY
THAT YOU LIKED THE IDEA OF A
SECOND CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
THAT WAS FOCUSED ON --
>> THINKING ABOUT IT.
>> SO I WAS WONDERING IF YOU
WERE PLANNING TO GO FORWARD WITH
THAT.
>> THINKING ABOUT IT.
A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO OPEN OUR COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, ID HAD AN EXPRESSION
THE CURE CAN'T BE WORSE THAN THE
POP U.S., RIGHT?
THAN THE PROBLEM ITSELF, RIGHT?
I STARTED BY SAYING THAT, AND I
CONTINUE TO SAY IT.
THE CURE CANNOT BE WORSE THAN
THE PROBLEM ITSELF.
WE'VE GOT TO GET OUR COUNTRY
OPEN.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR CALL
WITH --
[INAUDIBLE]
DID YOU SAY --
BACK IN ARENAS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I WANT FANS BACK IN THE
ARENAS --
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> NO.
WHENEVER WE'RE READY.
I MEAN, AS SOON AS WE CAN,
OBVIOUSLY.
AND THE FANS WANT TO BE BACK
TOO.
YOU KNOW, THEY WANT TO SEE
BASKETBALL AND BASEBALL AND
FOOTBALL AND HOCKEY.
THEY WANT TO SEE THEIR SPORTS.
THEY WANT TO GO OUT ONTO THE
GOLF COURSES IS AND BREATHE NICE
CLEAN, BEAUTIFUL FRESH AIR.
I CAN'T TELL YOU A DATE, BUT I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE SEPARATION FOR
THE REST OF OUR TIMES ON THE
PLANET.
WE NEED IT FOR THIS PERIOD OF
TIME, BUT EVENTUALLY PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO OCCUPY THOSE
SEATS IN ARENAS NEXT TO EACH
OTHER LIKE WE HAVE FOR ALL OF MY
LIFE AND ALL OF YOUR LIFE.
THEY WANT TO SIT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER AT RESTAURANTS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE, YOU KNOW,
6 FEET AWAY.
SOME RESTAURANT MAN CALLED UP
AND SAID, YEAH, I'M WORRIED
BECAUSE I HAVE A SMALL
RESTAURANT WITH NOT TOO MANY
SEATS, I THINK HE SAID 120.
AND HE SAID IF I PRACTICE WHAT
THIS IS, I'M DOWN TO 30 SEATS.
I CAN'T MAKE IT.
I SAID, DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT,
THAT'S FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
YOU'LL BE BACK TO YOUR NUMBER OF
SEATS.
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
OTHERWISE THAT MEANS YOUR
STADIUM IS HALF THE SIZE OF WHAT
IT WAS A MONTH AGO.
NO, NO.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE CLOSE
TOGETHER, BUT THEY'RE GOING TO
BE BREATHING AIR THAT'S NOT
GOING TO KILL PEOPLE.
PLEASE.
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT AUGUST, WHAT ARE YOUR --
>> I'M NOT COMMITTING TO IT.
I'M NOT COMMITTING TO IT.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHERE WE ARE.
THAT'D BE GREAT IF WE COULD, BUT
WE'RE GOING TO BE BACK TO GOOD
HEALTH SOON, IN MY OPINION.
WE'RE MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS.
AND WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
BECAUSE, AS TONY TOLD THE STORY
ABOUT THE RESTAURANT AND ABOUT
HOW THEY WERE SEPARATING SORT OF
AUTOMATICALLY, PEOPLE ARE DOING
THAT.
PEOPLE ARE DOING THAT.
THEY'RE STAYING IN THEIR HOMES.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO OUT.
THEY'RE DOING WHAT THEY KNOW IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT'S NOT VERY COMPLICATED.
IT'S, IN MANY WAYS IT'S A VERY
BEAUTIFUL THING TO SEE.
YEAH.
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
>> WE HAVE NO CONTINGENCY PLAN.
WE'RE HAVING THE VEX AT THE
END -- CONVENTION AT THE END OF
AUGUST, AND WE THINK WE'LL BE IN
GOOD SHAPE.
WE HAVE NO -- YOU KNOW, IT'S
GOING TO BE IN NORTH CAROLINA,
AS YOU KNOW, IN CHARLOTTE.
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
A GREAT CONVENTION.
I NOTICE -- I THINK WE HAD AN
OPPONENT IF, BUT I, I ALMOST
DIDN'T KNOW WHO IT WAS.
HE GOT .0001% OF THE VOTE.
BUT I HEARD HE DROPPED OUT THREE
OR FOUR WEEKS AGO.
I'M NOT SURE, MAYBE YOU COULD
TELL ME THAT.
'S THE KIND OF OPPONENT I HAD --
THAT'S THE KIND OF OPPONENT I
HAD.
AND HOPEFULLY WE HAVE ANOTHER
ONE JUST LIKE THAT.
>> LAWMAKERS ARE WORKING ON THE
NEXT ROUND OF RELIEF PACKAGES.
WHAT WAS NOT IN THE STIMULUS
PACKAGE THAT YOU SIGNED LAST
WEEK THAT YOU'D LIKE TO SEE?
>> WELL, I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
NEED MORE MONEY FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IT'S BEEN WORKING OUT SO WELL,
IT'S BEEN SO EFFICIENT.
THE BANKS ARE DOING AN
INCREDIBLE JOB.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO NEED MORE
MONEY THERE, I THINK, WE'LL SEE.
BASED ON THE FIRST COUPLE OF
DAYS, IT'S BEEN INCREDIBLE.
I THINK THAT RESTAURANTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT, THAT WOULD BE --
INCLUDE SPORTS LEAGUES, ALL
FORMS OF ENTERTAINMENT, GO BACK
TO THE ORIGINAL WHERE THEY GET
TAX DEDUCTIBILITY FOR WHAT HEIR
DOING AND FOR PEOPLE WHO COME IN
AND BUY TICKETS OR GO OUT FOR
MEALS, AND CORPORATIONS CAN THEN
SEND PEOPLE INTO THESE
RESTAURANTS WHO ARE GOING TO
HAVE A HARD TIME OTHERWISE
OPENING, IN MY OPINION.
AND THAT COULD BE THE SAME FOR
THE SPORTS LEAGUES.
WE WANT TO SEE FOR ENTERTAINMENT
AND FOR RESTAURANTS
DEDUCTIBILITY SO THAT
CORPORATIONS CAN TAKE A
DEDUCTION.
THEY'LL SEND THEIR EXECUTIVES
AND PEOPLE THERE, THEY'LL GET A
DEDUCTION.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
REALLY BRING LIFE BACK TO THE
RESTAURANTS, MAKE THEM HOTTER
BEFORE.
YOU KNOW, THEY USED TO HAVE IT,
AND WHEN THEY ENDED IT, IT WAS
REALLY NEVER THE SAME.
IT WAS NEVER THE SAME.
YEAH, PLEASE.
>> YOU JUST SAID YOU WANTED TO
KEEP AS FEW LIVES LOST AS
POSSIBLE IN THE PANDEMIC, BUT
THERE ARE STILL EIGHT GOVERNORS,
ALL REPUBLICANS, WHO HAVE
REFUSED TO ISSUE THE STATEWIDE
STAY AT ORDERS.
YOUR -- STAY AT HOME ORDERS.
YOUR OWN EXPERTS, INCLUDING
DR. FAUCI, SAY THAT'S THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO STOP THE VIRUS.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
WE HAVE A THING CALLED THE
CONSTITUTION, WHICH I CHERISH,
NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, THOSE GOVERNORS I
KNOW EVERY ONE OF THEM, THEY'RE
DOING A GREAT JOB.
THEY'RE BEING VERY, VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
AND AS YOU KNOW, I WANT THE
GOVERNORS TO BE RUNNING THINGS.
NOW, IN SOME CASES WE'LL
SUPERSEDE, BUT IN THIS CASE IT'S
NOT --
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> I THINK IT FENDS, IT DEPENDS
ON THE INDIVIDUAL STATE THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BUT THEY'RE DOING VERY WELL, AND
THEY'RE DOING A MAGNIFICENT JOB
IN RUNNING --
>> SOUTH CAROLINA HAS 1700 CASES
RIGHT NOW OF CORONAVIRUS.
UTAH HAS 1255.
I MEAN, ARE THESE NOT STATES
THAT SHOULD HAVE --
>> THEY'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
WELL, THAT'S A VERY SMALL --
>> IT'S LARGE OR THAN SOME
STATES THAT DO STAY AT HOME ORD.
>> IF I SAW SOMETHING WRONG, IF
I SAW A MASSIVE BREAKOUT OF
WHICH THAT'S NOT, I WOULD COME
DOWN VERY HARD --
>> [INAUDIBLE]
GETTING AHEAD OF THOSE NUMBERS
THOUGH?
>> NO, NOT IN THAT CASE.
BUT IN THE CASE -- I KNOW THE
STATES YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BY THE WAY, I THINK YOU'RE UP TO
92% OF THE COUNTRY IS COVERED.
AND FROM A CONSTITUTIONAL
STANDPOINT, THEY MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE.
THEY CALL THE SHOTS.
YES, JEFF, GO AHEAD.
>> A QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
YOU AND THE OTHERS HERE SAYING
PEOPLE NEED TO CONTINUE
FOLLOWING THE MITIGATION
EFFORTS, BUT YOU'RE ALSO SAYING
AGAIN THE CURE MUST NOT BE WORSE
THAN THE PROBLEM.
WHICH IS IT?
>> I'M JUST SAYING WE HAVE TO
GET THIS COUNTRY OPEN, JEFF.
IT HAS TO GET OPEN.
THIS COUNTRY WAS NOT DESIGNED TO
BE CLOSED.
SO WE HAVE THE GREATEST WE'VE
EVER HAD AND THEN WE'RE PAYING
PEOPLE TO STAY HOME?
THINK OF IT.
WE'RE PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO GO TO
WORK, HOW ABOUT THAT?
HOW DOES THAT PLAY?
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT --
>> AND THEY WANT TO GO TO WORK,
BY THE WAY.
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT -- THEY
DON'T WANT MONEY.
THIS COUNTRY IS GREAT.
WE'RE PAYING PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO WORK,
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
GO AHEAD, PLEASE.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
THIS IS OFF TOPIC.
THE ANNOUNCEMENT LAST NIGHT, YES
OR NO QUESTION NOT THAT WE
EXPECT YOU TO ANSWER THE YES OR
NO, BUT WASN'T MICHAEL ATKINSON
DOING THE JOB OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL, THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THE JOB HE WAS
SUPPOSED TO DO WHEN HE SIMPLY
TOOK THE WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINT
TO CONGRESS?
THAT HADN'T BEEN TAKEN
PREVIOUSLY?
WASN'T HE DOING THE JOB THAT HE
WAS SUPPOSED TO DO, THAT
AMERICAN TAXPAYER WERE PAYING
HIM TO DO?
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO FIRE HIM?
>> I THOUGHT HE DID A TERRIBLE
JOB, ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE.
HE TOOK A WHISTLEBLOWER REPORT
WHICH TURNED OUT TO BE A FAKE
REPORT, IT WAS FAKE, IT WAS
TOTALLY WRONG.
IT WAS ABOUT MY CONVERSATION
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
HE TOOK A FAKE REPORT, AND HE
BROUGHT IT TO CONGRESS.
WITH AN EMERGENCY, OKAY?
NOT A BIG TRUMP FAN, THAT I CAN
TELL YOU.
INSTEAD OF SAYING, AND WE
OFFERED THIS TO HIM, NO, NO, WE
WILL TAKE THE CONVERSATION --
WE'RE FORTUNATE WE HAD THAT
TRANSCRIPT.
IF WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT
TRANSCRIPT WITH THE KIND OF
DECEPTION AND DISHONESTY THAT
WAS PRACTICED BE BY THE
DEMOCRATS, I MIGHT NOT BE
STANDING HERE RIGHT NOW.
FORTUNATELY, WE HAD A
TRANSCRIPT, AND IT WAS A PERFECT
TRANSCRIPT.
EVEN THE LIEUTENANT COLONEL
ADMITTED IT WAS CORRECT.
OKAY, WAIT A MINUTE, WAIT A
MINUTE, YOU ASKED A QUESTION.
SO HE TOOK THIS WHISTLEBLOWER,
AND I KEEP SAYING WHERE'S THE
WHISTLEBLOWER, RIGHT?
AND WHY WAS THE WHISTLEBLOWER
ALLOWED TO DO THIS?
WHY WAS HE ALLOWED TO BE, YOU
CALL IT FRAUDULENT OR INCORRECT
TRANSCRIPT.
SO WE OFFERED THIS I.G., I DON'T
KNOW HIM, I DON'T THINK I EVER
MET HIM.
HE NEVER EVEN CAME IN TO SEE ME.
HOW CAN YOU DO THAT WITHOUT
SEEING THE PERSON?
NEVER CAME IN TO SEE ME, NEVER
REQUESTED TO SEE ME.
HE TOOK THIS TERRIBLE,
INACCURATE WHISTLEBLOWER REPORT,
RIGHT?
AND HE BROUGHT IT TO CONGRESS.
WE OFFERED TO HAVE HIM SEE MY
EXACT CONVERSATION.
IT WAS ALL ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION, BY THE WAY, THAT
WAS THE WHOLE THING WAS ABOUT
THE CONVERSATION, RIGHT?
AND THEN AFTER HE SAW IT, HE
MUST HAVE SAID, WOW, BECAUSE AS
I'VE SAID IT MANY TIMES AND IT
DRIVES YOU PEOPLE CRAZY, IT WAS
A PERFECT CONVERSATION.
SO INSTEAD OF GOING AND SAYING,
GEE, THIS IS A TERRIBLE THING HE
SAID ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
CONVERSATION, WELL, IT WAS A
FRAUD.
I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
AND, BY THE WAY, YOU HAVE THE
WHISTLEBLOWER, WHERE'S THE
INFORMER, RIGHT?
AND HERE'S ANOTHER QUESTION.
REMEMBER BEFORE DID THE, BEFORE
I REVEALED THE REAL
CONVERSATION, WHERE'S THE SECOND
WHISTLEBLOWER?
REMEMBER THE SECOND WHISTLE --
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
THERE WAS GOING TO BE A SECOND
WHITTLE BLOWER.
BUT AFTER I -- WHISTLEBLOWER.
BUT AFTER I GAVE THE
CONVERSATION, HE JUST WENT AWAY.
HE MIRACULOUSLY WENT AWAY.
WHERE'S THE INFORMER?
BECAUSE IT WAS GOING TO BE THIS
INFORMER.
MAYBE SCHIFF WAS THE INFORMER.
DO YOU EVER THINK OF THAT?
HE'S A CORRUPT GUY, HE'S A
CORRUPT POLITICIAN.
SO, LISTEN, SAY THIS: WHERE'S
THE INFORMER?
REMEMBER, THE INFORMER WAS
COMING FORWARD.
BUT, YOU SEE, I DID ONE THING
THAT SURPRISED EVERYBODY.
THIS GENTLEMAN RIGHT HERE SAID,
BOY, THAT WAS A SHOCKER.
I REVEALED THE CONVERSATION.
I GOT APPROVAL FROM UKRAINE
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT
WITHOUT THEIR APPROVAL.
AND THEY SAID, ABSOLUTELY, YOU
DID NOTHING WRONG.
BY THE WAY, PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE, FOREIGN MINISTER SAID
HE DID NOTHING
OVER THAT, WITH 196-0 BY THE
REPUBLICAN, NOT ONE DISSENTING
REPUBLICAN VOTE, DISHONEST
DEMOCRATS IMPEACHED A PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT MAN IS A DISGRACE TO IGS.
LET'S GO NEXT, PLEASE.
HE'S A TOTAL DISGRACE.
>> DID YOU RUN BY YOUR DECISION
TO DISMISS THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
BY SENATOR --
>> WE'LL GET OFF THIS.
PEOPLE WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
THAT'S MY DECISION.
I HAVE THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT.
EVEN THE FAKE NEWS LAST NIGHT
SAID HE HAS THE ABSOLUTE RIGHT
TO DO IT.
BUT ASK HIM, WHY DIDN'T YOU GO
AND SEE THE ACTUAL CONVERSATION?
THERE WAS NO RUSH.
HE SAID OH, WE'VE GOT TO RUSH
IT.
HE EVEN SAID IT WAS POLITICALLY
BIASED.
HE ACTUALLY SAID THAT.
THE REPORT COULD HAVE BEEN --
YOU KNOW WHO THE WHISTLEBLOWER
IS AND SO DO YOU AND SO DOES
EVERYBODY IN THE ROOM AND SO DO
I.
THEY GIVE THIS WHISTLEBLOWER
STATUS THAT HE DOESN'T DESERVE.
HE'S A FAKE WHISTLEBLOWER AND
FRANKLY, SOMEBODY OUGHT TO SUE
HIS ASS OFF.
THAT'S ENOUGH OF THE
WHISTLEBLOWER, PLEASE.
>>
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
-- HE HAS ACCEPTED 1,000 OF THEM
FROM THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
ARE YOU CONCERNED --
>> WHAT HE DIDN'T SAY.
LET ME TELL WHAT YOU HE DIDN'T
SAY.
TWO VERY GOOD FRIENDS OF MINE
BROUGHT HIM THE WHISTLEBLOWER,
BROUGHT HIM THOSE VENTILATORSING
RIGHT TWO VERY GOOD FRIENDS OF
MINE.
THEY BROUGHT THEM.
IF YOU'D LIKE THEIR NAME, I'LL
GIVE YOU THEIR NAME.
BUT THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T MENTION
THAT.
IT CAME THROUGH THE CHINESE --
THE COUNTRY OF CHINA.
BUT THEY WERE GIVEN BY TWO
FRIENDS OF MINE.
BUT HE DIDN'T TELL YOU THAT.
NOW, THE GOVERNOR ALSO -- YOU'LL
SEE WHEN YOU READ THE LETTER.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO ASKED FOR
40,000.
HE WANTED 40,000 VENTILATORS.
NOW, THE GOVERNOR AS YOU KNOW
HAD A CHANCE TO GET 16,000 A FEW
YEARS AGO.
HE DECIDED NOT TO GET THAT.
THE STATE OF NEW YORK HAS ASKED
FOR HELP.
I'VE GIVEN THEM FOUR HOSPITALS,
FOUR MEDICAL CENTERS, THEN I
GAVE THEM AN ADDITIONAL
HOSPITAL.
THEN I GAVE THEM MILITARY PEOPLE
TO OPERATE THE HOSPITAL.
THEY WERE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
COVID HOSPITALS.
THE BOAT, THE SHIP IS NOT.
INTERESTING THING HAPPENED WITH
THE SHIP.
PEOPLE AREN'T IN EXODUS BECAUSE
THERE'S NOBODY DRIVING, NOBODY
TAKING MOTORCYCLE RIDES DOWN THE
WEST SIDE HIGHWAY AT 100 MILES
AN HOUR.
PEOPLE ARE AWAY.
SO PEOPLE AREN'T BEING INJURED.
NOW THEY'RE ASKING WHETHER OR
NOT WE COULD OPEN UP THE SHIP
FOR COVID.
WE HAVE GIVEN THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK MORE THAN ANYBODY HAS
EVER BEEN GIVEN IN A LONG TIME.
I WAS GOING TO SAY IN HISTORY,
BUT IN A LONG TIME AND I THINK
HE'S HAPPY.
BUT I THINK THAT -- BECAUSE I
WATCH WHAT HE SAID TODAY AND IT
WAS FINE.
I WOULDN'T SAY GRACIOUS.
IT WASN'T GRACIOUS.
IT WAS OKAY.
I MUST TELL YOU, GAVIN NEW S&P M
HAS BEEN GRACIOUS.
LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA, THE JOB
WE'VE DONE AND ALL OF CALL
IMPORTANT.
CALIFORNIA.
>> WHY DOES IT MATTER IF
THEY'RE GRACIOUS OR NOT
GRACIOUS.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT WE'VE GIVEN --
MAYOR DE BLASIO HAS BEEN VERY
NICE.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHAT WE'VE GIVEN
HIM.
WE BROUGHT HIM MORE VENTILATORS
TOO YESTERDAY.
BUT NOBODY HAS BEEN GIVEN LIKE
NEW YORK.
AND I THINK -- I KNOW HE
APPRECIATES IT.
HE JUST CAN'T QUITE GET THE
WORDS OUT.
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
>> WHEN HE SAYS HE NEEDS 40,000
--
>> PLEASE, GO AHEAD.
>> DR. FAUCI'S COMMENTS --
>> WHICH ONE'S IN.
>> DR. FAUCI'S COMMENTS.
ON THE REPRODUCTIVE VALUE OF THE
VIRUS, THE WHO HAD 2 TO 2.6,
OTHER HADS IT A PERCENTAGE POINT
OR TWO HIGHER.
DO WE HAVE A NEW NUMBER BASED ON
THOSE MITIGATION TECHNIQUES.
HAVE WE MANAGED TO BRING IT
DOWN?
>> I THINK DEB, YOU SHOULD
ANSWER THAT.
DR. BIRX.
GO AHEAD.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION AND IT'S WHY ALL OF THE
MODELERS AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THEM, AGAIN, THEY'RE
RE-EVALUATING ALL OF THEIR
MODELS IN LIGHT OF THE LEVEL OF
THE IMPACT OF THE MITIGATION.
REMEMBER, NONE OF US HAD REALLY
BEEN THROUGH THIS BEFORE.
SO WHEN WE MODELED SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND DISTANCING AND
STAYING AT HOME AND ALL OF THESE
PIECES, THAT HAD NEVER REALLY
COME INTO THE MODEL BEFORE.
THEY'RE WORKING ON THAT VERY
DILIGENTLY NOW.
OF COURSE, JUST TO BE CLEAR, WE
WON'T KNOW HOW VALID THE MODELS
ARE UNTIL WE MOVE ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE EPIDEMIC.
WHAT WE'RE TRIANGULATING RIGHT
NOW AND INSTEAD OF WORKING ON --
OR NOT, WE'RE LOOKING AT TESTING
AND TRIANGULATING TESTING, TEST
POSITIVE, CASE,
HOSPITALIZATIONS, ICUs AND THE
WHOLE -- AND OF COURSE THE
RECOVERIES, BECAUSE THAT'S ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT TO US.
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE EQUAL NUMBER OF STATES
WITH LESS THAN 5% POSITIVE,
DESPITE HIGH LEVELS OF TESTING.
SO THERE'S STATES THAT ARE
MITIGATING AND MAKING THIS WORK.
THERE ARE ALSO THE STATES THAT
YOU KNOW OF, THE 18 STATES THAT
HAVE THE LARGER OUTBREAKS AND
WE'RE WATCHING THEM VERY
CAREFULLY, TRIANGULATING FOR
THEM ALL OF THE INFORMATION TO
ENSURE THAT CLIENTS WHO COME TO
THE HOSPITAL ARE CARED FOR.
AND THEN THERE'S STATES IN THE
MIDDLE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT, ARE THEY CHANGING OR
NOT.
EACH OF THOSE STATES AND EACH OF
THOSE EPIDEMICS WITHIN THOSE
STATES MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT
R-VALUE AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT AND IT'S
VERY VARIABLE IN EACH OF THESE
FACTORS BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS,
AND I THINK GOING INTO THIS
WEEKEND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW
THIS, SPAIN AND ITALY ARE MOVING
THROUGH THIS.
THEY ARE SEEING THEIR NUMBER OF
CASES DROP.
THEY'RE SEEING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN HOSPITALS DROP.
WE ARE ABOUT -- ON OUR MODELS
AND ON THE ACTUAL DATA ABOUT 12
DAYS BEHIND THEM.
AT THE SAME TIME, WE SEE IN THE
UNITED STATES REALLY GOOD CASE
STUDIES OF THE IMPACT OF
WASHINGTON STATE, OF CALIFORNIA,
AND A SERIES OF SMALLER STATES
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO LEARN FROM
THEM HOW YOU TO DO SURVEILLANCE
AND WITH THESE NEW HHS, ABBOTT
ID NOW KITS -- I WANT TO THANK
ADMIRAL GERARD FOR GETTING THEM
OUT, BEING ABLE TO LOOK AT
TESTING IN A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
WAY SO WE CAN DO SURVEILLANCE
AND MITIGATION SIMULTANEOUSLY SO
WE CAN ANSWER THAT VERY
QUESTION.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT
TO ANSWER AT THIS MOMENT ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE EACH
METRO CLUSTER IS ON A DIFFERENT
PATHWAY AS THEY MOVE THROUGH --
MOVE THROUGH THE EPIDEMIC AND I
THINK WE OUGHT TO EMPHASIZE
"THROUGH."
BECAUSE WE SEE ITALY, WE SEE
SPAIN MOVING THROUGH AND WE HOPE
TO BE IN THAT SAME POSITION.
AT THE SAME TIME AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID, HE'S CONCERNED
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT
IS SUCCUMBING TO THIS VIRUS.
WE ALL ARE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE MAKING SURE
THAT IN THIS TRY LAYINGS,
THEY'RE TRACKING -- TRY
ANGULATION, THEY'RE TRACKING
MINUTE BY MINUTE.
AND ALSO BEING FLEXIBLE AND
RESPONSIVE TO HAVE DOD TAKE
1,000 HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS OUT
OF THEIR MEDICAL CORPS IS A VERY
BIG DEAL.
I WAS IN THE MEDICAL CORPS FOR
29 YEARS.
WE NEVER DID THAT.
SO THIS IS SAYING WE RESPECT AND
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE AND
VALUE OF THE AMERICAN LIVES.
BUT THE R-VALUES WILL BE
VARIABLE BY STATE.
>> WE TALK ABOUT COUNTY BY
COUNTY --
>> BEFORE I DO THAT.
WE HAD BREAKING NEWS LAST NIGHT.
YOU SAW THAT.
WHERE I THINK THE PROBABLE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS WILL BE JOE BIDEN AND
HE AGREED THAT I WAS CORRECT
WHEN I STOPPED PEOPLE FROM CHINA
VERY EARLY, VERY, VERY EARLY,
FROM COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY AND
DR. FAUCI SAID THAT WAS A VERY
BIG MOMENT BECAUSE IT WOULD BE A
MUCH DIFFERENT PICTURE WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW HAD WE ALLOWED
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FROM SPECIFIC AREA, I
DON'T HAVE TO GO INTO IT, FROM
CHINA, TO COME IN HIGHLY
INFECTED.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A VERY
DIFFERENT THING.
THE OTHER THING -- SO I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT HE DID
BECAUSE I WAS CALLED XENOPHOBIC,
RACIST, I WAS CALLED MANY THINGS
WHEN I DID THAT VERY EARLY AND I
GOT A LOT OF CREDIT FOR IT IN
THE FEDERALIST BECAUSE THE
FEDERALIST COVERED THE WHOLE
JOURNEY AND THEY SAID TRUMP WAS
-- I DIDN'T SPEAK TO THE AUTHOR,
RESPECTED AUTHOR.
THEY SAID TRUMP WAS RIGHT AT
EVERY SINGLE MOVE AND ON TOP OF
THAT HE WAS GOING THROUGH A FAKE
IMPEACHMENT, A HOAX, I WAS GOING
THROUGH A HOAX WHEN I MADE THE
DECISION.
AND THAT DOES TAKE A LITTLE TIME
AND CERTAINLY A LITTLE THINKING
TIME BUT I APPRECIATED THE FACT
THAT JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCED LAST
NIGHT THAT HE NOW AGREES THAT I
WAS CORRECT.
YOU SAW THE REPORT COME OUT.
THAT I WAS CORRECT WHEN I
STOPPED PEOPLE FROM CHINA COMING
IN AT A VERY EARLY DATE.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT THE
CAPTAIN KROSHER, THE COMMANDER
THAT WAS REMOVED.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
VIDEOS OF SAILORS CHEERING FOR
HIM AS HE LEFT.
OUR REPORTING SHOWS THAT SOME
SAILOR VERSUS SAID THEY ARE
WORRIED TO REENLIST BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT CONVINCED THAT
COMMANDERS ARE TAKING CARE OF
THEIR HEALTH AND TAKING CARE OF
THEM.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> HERE WE HAVE ONE OF THE
GREATEST SHIPS IN THE WORLD,
NUCLEAR AIRCRAFT CARRIER,
INCREDIBLE SHIP WITH THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE AND YOU
HAD ABOUT 120 THAT WERE
INFECTED.
NOW, I GUESS THE CAPTAIN STOPPED
IN VIETNAM AND PEOPLE GOT OFF IN
VIETNAM.
PERHAPS YOU DON'T DO THAT IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC OR
SOMETHING THAT LOOKED LIKE IT
WAS GOING TO BE.
YOU KNOW, HISTORY WOULD SAY YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY STOP AND LET
YOUR SAILORS GET OFF.
NUMBER ONE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, HE WROTE A
LETTER.
THE LETTER WAS A FIVE-PAGE
LETTER FROM A CAPTAIN AND THE
LETTER WAS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THAT'S NOT APPROPRIATE.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
AND THESE ARE TOUGH PEOPLE.
THESE ARE TOUGH, STRONG PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT IT LOOKED TERRIBLE, TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU.
NOW, THEY MADE THEIR DECISION --
I DIDN'T MAKE THE DECISION.
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE WAS
INVOLVED AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
WERE INVOLVED.
I THOUGHT I WAS TERRIBLE, WHAT
HE DID, TO WRITE A LETTER.
I MEAN, THIS ISN'T A CLASS ON
LITERATURE.
THIS IS A CAPTAIN OF A MASSIVE
SHIP THAT'S NUCLEAR POWERED.
AND HE SHOULDN'T BE TALKING THAT
WAY IN A LETTER.
HE COULD CALL AND ASK AND
SUGGEST BUT HE STOPPED IN
VIETNAM, A LOT OF PEOPLE GOT OFF
THE BOAT.
THEY CAME BACK AND THEY HAD
INFECTION.
AND I THOUGHT IT WAS
INAPPROPRIATE FOR THE CAPTAIN OF
A SHIP TO -- I DON'T WANT TO
COMMENT AS TO WHETHER OR NOT,
BUT I AGREE WITH THEIR DECISION
100%.
IN THE BACK, PLEASE.
>> JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY JUST
ATTACKED YOU IN A TWEET, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE SEEN IT.
>> HE JUST WHAT?
>> ATTACKED YOU.
>> HE DIDN'T WRITE ANYTHING.
HE HAS PROFESSIONALS  FROM THE
DEMOCRATS WRITING.
>> LET ME READ WHAT HE SAID.
HE SAYS DONALD TRUMP IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CORONAVIRUS
BUT HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
FAILING TO PREPARE OUR NATION TO
RESPOND TO IT.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT, SIR?
>> HE DIDN'T WRITE THAT.
THAT WAS DONE BY A DEMOCRAT
OPERATIVE.
HE DOESN'T WRITE.
HE DOESN'T -- HE'S PROBABLY NOT
EVEN WATCHING RIGHT NOW.
AND IF HE IS, HE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT HE'S WATCHING.
BUT JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND, IT
WAS VERY NICE WHAT THEY WROTE.
YOU KNOW, THEY RELEASED IT AT A
STRANGE TIME, SORT OF A STRANGE
TIME TO RELEASE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
BUT HE ADMITTED I WAS RIGHT.
AND IF YOU READ THE FEDERALIST
STORY WHICH MOST OF YOU WON'T,
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO, BUT
YOU'D LEARN SOMETHING BECAUSE IF
YOU -- IT GOES THROUGH A CHART,
TIMES.
I WAS EARLY.
DR. FAUCI, I DON'T THINK HE'S
CHANGED HIS MIND BUT HE SAID IT
WAS A VERY IMPORTANT STEP WHEN
WE STOPPED CHINA FROM COMING IN
FROM THE SPECIFIC AREA THAT WAS
HEAVILY INFECTED.
WE WOULD HAVE A WHOLE DIFFERENT
THING RIGHT NOW.
SO I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT JOE
BIDEN SAID.
I DON'T REALLY CARE.
AND AGAIN, I SEE -- EVERY ONCE
IN A WHILE I'LL SAY SOMETHING,
I'M MAKE A SPEECH AND IT WILL BE
CRITIQUED AND I GET THIS
BEAUTIFUL, BRILLIANT CRITIQUE.
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T WRITE THAT.
HE WISHED HE DID BUT HE DIDN'T.
GO AHEAD, PLEASE.
BACK.
>> CHINA HAS WARNED OF A
RESURGENCE OF THE VIRUS.
HAS THE U.S. DEVELOPED A PLAN IF
IN FACT A SECOND WAVE OF THE
VIRUS DOES IN FACT OCCUR HERE IN
THE COUNTRY?
>>> YES, WE DO.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT OBVIOUSLY
IS PARALLEL WITH THINKING ABOUT
THE POSSIBILITY AS I MENTIONED A
LITTLE WHILE AGO ABOUT
MITIGATION ALLOWING US TO TURN
THE CORNER VERY MUCH ON THE
FRONT BURNER IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE DO BECAUSE THE RISK OF
THERE BEING A RESURGENCE IS
REAL.
SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO, AND I
BELIEVE I SAID THIS BEFORE BUT
IT'S WORTH REPEATING, THAT WHAT
WE NEED TO HAVE IN PLACE AND WE
WILL HAVE THAT IN PLACE IS THAT
AS YOU THEN PULL BACK, YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF IN A
VERY PRISTINE, PRECISE WAY, DO
THE KIND OF CONTAINMENT WHEN YOU
DO SEE IT.
BECAUSE REMEMBER, WHEN YOU GET
TO MITIGATION, CONTAINMENT TAKES
THE BACK SEAT BECAUSE YOU'RE
JUST STRUGGLING TO MITIGATE BUT
WHEN YOU GET IT DOWN, YOU NEED
TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T RESURGE.
THAT WILL REQUIRE THE ABILITY TO
TEST, TO IDENTIFY, TO ISOLATE
AND TO DO CONTACT TRACING.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO HAVE IN
PLACE AND HOPEFULLY WE WILL AT
THE TIME THAT WE THEN PULL BACK.
>> A QUESTION FOR --
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
YOU MENTIONED THE PLASMA, THE
PLASMA OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
INFECTED AND HAVE RECOVERED AND
ARE TRANSFERRING IT TO FAMILY
MEMBERS.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH, IS THAT
WORKING AND A CASE BY CASE
BASIS, WHAT ARE THE RESULTS OF
THAT?
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
>> SO THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE
SOMEONE WHO HAS RECOVERED FROM
THE VIRUS DOESN'T HAVE THE VIRUS
IN THEIR SYSTEM AT ALL, YOU CAN
TAKE PLASMA -- THIS IS A PRETTY
ROUTINE PROCEDURE.
YOU CAN DONATE A COUPLE TIMES A
WEEK, A COUPLE TIMES A MONTH AND
GIVE THAT PLASMA.
THAT PLASMA CONTAINS THE
PROTEINS IN THE BLOOD THAT HAVE
THE ANTIBODIES AGAINST THE
VIRUS.
YOU CAN TAKE THAT, PROCESS IT
AND GIVE IT TO SOMEONE WHO IS
ILL.
AND SO THAT ALLOWS YOU TO
TRANSFER IMMUNITY.
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE MATCHED BY
FAMILY OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
SINCE LAST TUESDAY, THE TUESDAY
BEFORE LAST, WE'VE ALLOWED
ACADEMIC CENTERS AND OTHER LAB
LABORATORIES AND HOSPITALS
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO DO THIS ON
A COMPASSIONATE USE BASIS.
WE PULLED THIS TOGETHER IN AN
EXPANDED ACCESS PROGRAM AND RUN
IT THROUGH THE RED CROSS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE GREATEST SYSTEM
AND CAPACITY FOR DOING THIS.
THIS ALLOWS US TO SCALE UP SO
THAT WHEN PEOPLE GET SICK WE CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE THESE DONATED
PLASMA PACKS GIVEN TO THE
PATIENTS WHO ARE SICK.
>> SOME OF US DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE IT OR RECOVERED, WHAT
SHOULD PEOPLE BE DOING?
>> WE STARTED WITH THE RED CROSS
IN THIS PROGRAM.
WE MADE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
YESTERDAY.
WE ARE PLANNING TO SCALE THAT UP
AND WE'LL HAVE MORE INFORMATION
THIS WEEK.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE
SYSTEMS IN PLACE.
IT'S A SUPERB QUESTION.
>> CAN YOU CLARIFY THE
SITUATION WITH 3M RIGHT NOW?
GERMANY SAYS THERE WAS AN ACT OF
PIRACY THAT 200,000 MASKS WERE
APPARENTLY DIVERTED FROM
THAILAND TO THE UNITED STATES
INSTEAD OF TO BERLIN.
DID THAT ACTUALLY HAPPEN?
SHOULD 3M BE FULFILLING
CONTRACTS FOR --
>> WE'RE VERY DISAPPOINTED WITH
3M.
THEY SHOULD BE TAKING CARE OF
OUR COUNTRY.
THEY CAN SELL TO OTHERS BUT THEY
SHOULD TAKE CARE OF OUR COUNTRY.
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE DEALT WITH
THEM HAVE DEALT SUCCESSFULLY
WITH MANY COMPANIES OVER THE
LAST MONTH.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE WAY 3M HAS
TREATED OUR COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T FRANKLY LIKE THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF 3M.
AND NO -- YOU SAID PIRACY,
RIGHT?
PIRACY.
THERE'S BEEN NO ACT OF PIRACY.
IT'S THE OPPOSITE.
3M HAS NOT TREATED OUR COUNTRY
WELL AND IF THEY DO, GREAT.
AND IF THEY DON'T, THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE A HELL OF A PRICE TO
PAY, OKAY.
I SAY IT THAT WAY.
I WATCHED HIM ON TELEVISION, ON
SOMETHING, TALKING ABOUT -- IT'S
SO HARD TO BELIEVE, SO HARD TO
FATHOM.
THEY OUGHT TO GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER BECAUSE I GOT INVOLVED
AND I LOOKED AT WHAT HAPPENED
AND THEY HAVE NOT -- 3M HAS NOT
TREATED OUR COUNTRY WELL.
>> CAN YOU CLARIFY ABOUT THE --
>> GO AHEAD, PLEASE.
>> WAS THAT DIVERTED.
>> WE'LL GET YOU THE
INFORMATION.
>> I WAS WONDERING ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING AS FAR AS PATIENTS
IN REGARDS TO CORONAVIRUS, IT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER BUT WHAT
DOES --
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
>> WHAT IS THE QUESTION?
IS THE INCIDENCE OF CORONAVIRUS
--
>>
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
>> RIGHT NOW, THIS IS BEING
LOOKED AT IN A NATURAL HISTORY
STUDY.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY DEFINITIVE
INFORMATION TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
ANY COMMENT ON THAT.
IT'S AN OBVIOUS GOOD QUESTION
BECAUSE IT MIGHT BE A WAY FOR US
TO GET SOME INTERESTING AND
POTENTIALLY IMPORTANT DATA AS TO
THE ROLE OF THOSE MEDICATIONS.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS NOW
BEING LOOKED AT BUT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY DATA TO BE ABLE TO SAY
DEFINITIVELY.
>> I HOPE THEY USE THE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
THEY CAN DO IT WITH Z-PACK
SUBJECT TO YOUR DOCTOR'S
APPROVAL.
I HOPE THEY USE IT.
I TELL YOU WHAT, WHAT DO YOU
HAVE TO LOSE?
IN SOME CASES THEY'RE IN BAD
SHAPE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
IT'S BEEN OUT THERE FOR A LONG
TIME AND I HOPE THEY USE IT.
AND THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
-- WORK WITH DOCTORS, GET WHAT
YOU HAVE TO GET.
BUT WE HAVE IT STOCKPILED AND
IT'S -- WE HAVE A LOT OF IT AND
WE'RE GETTING MORE OF IT AND AS
I TOLD YOU, I SPOKE TO PRIME
MINISTER MODI.
WE'RE GETTING MORE OF IT.
IT'S BEEN USED FOR A LONG TIME
AND THEREFORE IT'S PASSED THE
SAFETY TEST.
FDA HAS BEEN TERRIFIC.
DR. HAHN I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
TOO.
I'VE SEEN SOME RESULTS.
NOW, IT'S EARLY.
I GUESS IT'S EARLY.
BUT -- AND THEY SHOULD LOOK AT
THE LUPUS THING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT SAYS.
THERE'S A RUMOR OUT THERE THAT
-- BECAUSE IT TAKES CARE OF
LUPUS VERY EFFECTIVELY AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
IT'S A DRUG THAT'S USED FOR
LUPUS.
SO THERE'S A STUDY OUT THERE
THAT SAYS PEOPLE DON'T HAVE
LUPUS HAVEN'T BEEN CATCHING THIS
VIRUS.
MAYBE IT'S TRUE.
MAYBE IT'S NOT.
WHY DON'T YOU INVESTIGATE THAT.
AND THERE'S ALSO OTHER STUDIES
-- YOU KNOW, WITH MALARIA, THAT
THE MALARIA COUNTRIES, PEOPLE
THAT TAKE THIS DRUG FOR MALARIA
WHICH IS VERY EFFECTIVE FOR
MALARIA, THAT THOSE COUNTRIES
HAVE VERY LITTLE OF THIS VIRUS.
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU'RE GOING TO CHECK IT OUT.
BUT I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD -- IF
IT WERE ME -- IN FACT, I MIGHT
DO IT ANYWAY.
I MAY TAKE IT.
OKAY?
I MAY TAKE IT AND I'LL HAVE TO
ASK MY DOCTORS ABOUT THAT BUT I
MAY TAKE IT.
YEAH, PLEASE, GO AHEAD.
>> LAST COUPLE DAYS YOU'VE BEEN
REALLY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT RUSSIA
AND SAUDI ARABIA COMING TOGETHER
ON A DEAL ON OIL.
IN THE LAST 24 HOURS OPEC
THOUGHT THERE WAS PUSHBACK.
>> I'VE BEEN AGAINST OPEC ALL
MY LIFE.
BECAUSE WHAT IS IT?
IT'S AN ILLEGAL -- YOU COULD
CALL IT A CARTEL, A MONOPOLY, A
LOT OF DIFFERENT NAMES FOR IT.
BUT IT BROKE DOWN VERY
VIOLENTLY, VERY VIOLENTLY.
SO I DON'T CARE ABOUT OPEC.
I REALLY DON'T.
I COULDN'T CARE LESS ABOUT OPEC.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO SETTLE
IT.
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DESTROYED.
THEY'RE DESTROYING THEMSELVES IF
THEY DON'T.
RUSSIA, IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT --
WE HAD A VERY GOOD CONVERSATION,
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND MYSELF.
VERY GOOD.
BUT RUSSIA, BIG PART OF THEIR
ECONOMIC WELL-BEING IS FROM OIL.
WELL, OIL IS AT A RECORD LOW.
NOBODY'S EVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
IT'S ACTUALLY LOWER THAN YOU
EVEN THINK.
AND IT'S TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S TO SAUDI ARABIA'S
ADVANTAGE.
THEY TOLD ME THEY'RE DISCUSSING
-- SAUDI ARABIA WENT FURTHER
THAN THAT.
HE THINKS A DEAL IS GOING TO BE
MADE AT 10 MILLION BARRELS
REDUCTION.
MAYBE MORE THAN THAT.
HE INDICATED IT WOULD MOST
LIKELY BE MORE THAN THAT.
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
AS FAR AS OPEC IS CONCERNED, I
MEAN, I WAS AGAINST OPEC FOR
YEARS AND YEARS BECAUSE I
THOUGHT IT WAS VERY UNFAIR TO
OUR COUNTRY.
THE BEAUTIFUL THING IS, WE HAVE
BUILT ONE OF THE GREAT -- ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'VE DONE IS CREATED
SO MUCH, WE PRODUCE, WE'RE THE
NUMBER ONE PRODUCER IN THE WORLD
RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T LIKE IT FOR A DIFFERENT
REASON, BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
HURT A LOT OF JOBS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THIS PRICE.
IT'S GOING TO HURT A LOT OF
JOBS.
NOW, WITH ALL OF THAT BEING
SAID, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
DRIVING, PAYING 90-CENTS A
GALLON.
DID YOU EVER HEAR OF THAT?
WHAT'S THAT, 1952 OR SOMETHING?
ALL RIGHT.
FROM THAT STANDPOINT -- YOU KNOW
WHAT, I AM A BIG BELIEVER IN OUR
GREAT ENERGY BUSINESS AND WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF OUR ENERGY
BUSINESS AND IF I HAVE TO DO
TARIFFS ON OIL COMING FROM
OUTSIDE OR IF I HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO PROTECT OUR
THOUSANDS AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF ENERGY WORKERS, AND OUR GREAT
COMPANIES THAT PRODUCE ALL THESE
JOBS, I'LL DO WHATEVER I HAVE TO
DO.
OKAY?
YEAH, MA'AM, GO AHEAD.
>> YOU TWEETED A LITTLE WHILE
AGO ABOUT HOW SAD IT IS FOR
KIDS, THEY DON'T HAVE LITTLE
LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
I'M WONDERING IF YOU'RE WILLING
TO SHARE ABOUT YOUR YOUNGEST
CHILD AND HOW HE'S DEALING WITH
LIFE SHELTERING IN PLACE, NOT
GOING TO SCHOOL, NO SPORTS.
>> WELL, HE'S A GOOD ATHLETE
AND HE LOVES SOCCER AND HE'S
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
EVERYTHING'S SHUT DOWN.
HE'S IN HIS ROOM.
HE'S HAPPY.
BUT HE'S NOT AS HAPPY AS HE
COULD BE.
HE'D LIKE TO BE PLAYING SPORTS.
BARON.
AND LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT WE HAVE TO GET BACK.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK.
REMEMBER THAT.
AND WE HAVE TO GET BACK SOON.
OKAY.
>> ON THE JOBS REPORT THE NUMBER
--
>> YOU GUYS EVER STOP?
YOU WANT TO KEEP GOING FOR A
LITTLE WHILE?
HUH?
I MEAN, DO YOU EVER STOP?
HOW MANY TIMES DO YOU ASK --
ACTUALLY A LOT OF GOOD
QUESTIONS.
GO AHEAD.
BUT KEEP GOING, YES?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BLAME ME I
KEPT IT GOING TOO LONG.
PEOPLE SAID -- EVERY TIME YOU
ASK -- I MEAN, NO, IT'S AMAZING.
I'M TELLING YOU.
EVERY HAND WENT UP.
I THOUGHT WE'VE GONE THROUGH --
I THINK EVERY SINGLE HAND WENT
UP THE LAST TIME.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT SHOWS YOU?
IT SHOWS YOU THAT YOU LOVE WHAT
YOU DO.
GO AHEAD.
>> WE DO LOVE WHAT WE DO.
>> YOU DO.
SOME OF YOU DO IT WELL.
NOT ALL OF YOU.
GO AHEAD.
I'M NOT LOOKING AT YOU, BY THE
WAY.
>> WE DID GET THE JOBS REPORT
NUMBERS YESTERDAY.
IT'S A SMALL PORTION BECAUSE
IT'S THE FIRST HALF OF MARCH.
WAS THERE ANYTHING IN THERE THAT
WAS ANY SIGN OF OPTIMISM?
OBVIOUSLY WE ALL SAW THE
NUMBERS, DOWN IN RETAIL, DOWN IN
HOSPITALITY.
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU SAID OKAY,
MAYBE WITH THIS VIRUS --
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
>> LOOK, THE JOB NUMBERS ARE
WHAT THEY ARE.
WE ASKED EVERYBODY TO GO HOME,
DON'T WORK.
SO THE NUMBERS ARE GOING TO BE
ASTRONOMICAL.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
I UNDERSTOOD THAT.
I KNOW SOMEBODY SAID THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE MEANINGLESS AND THEN
THEY TOOK THAT TO MEAN OH, JOBS
DON'T MEAN ANYTHING AND IT WAS
JUST ANOTHER FAKE NEWS STORY.
IT WASN'T ME THAT SAID IT, BY
THE WAY.
IT WAS A VERY SMART PERSON.
BUT THEY MEANT IT.
BY SAYING IT REALLY IS -- THAT'S
WHY I ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION
VERY CAREFULLY.
THE NUMBERS ARE WHAT THEY ARE.
WE KNOW THE NUMBERS WERE GOING
TO BE MASSIVE BECAUSE WE TOLD
EVERYBODY TO GO HOME AND LOCK
YOUR DOORS, ESSENTIALLY.
DON'T COME TO WORK.
YOU CAN'T COME TO WORK.
DON'T GO OUTSIDE.
DON'T BREATHE.
DON'T DO ANYTHING.
WE'VE GOT TO OPEN UP OUR
COUNTRY.
BUT I KNOW THAT IT'S COMING
BACK.
AND IN MY OPINION, IT WILL COME
BACK VERY STRONG.
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS ENERGY,
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS DEMAND.
AND SOME GOOD THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW.
THERE'S ONE HABIT THAT AS YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF YOU HAVE COVERED
ME FOR A LONG TIME, I WAS NEVER
A BIG BELIEVER IN SHAKING HANDS
BUT I DECIDED IF YOU DON'T SHAKE
HANDS YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE
WINNING A LOT OF CONTESTS.
RIGHT NOW, I'M NOT SURE HAVE YOU
TO SHAKE HANDS ANYMORE.
COUPLE OF PEOPLE HAVE TOLD ME,
DEBORAH, YOU TOLD ME THAT IF WE
DIDN'T SHAKE HANDS THE INCIDENTS
OF FLU -- FLU'S A BIG DEAL ALSO,
AND THAT FLU MIGHT BE CUT DOWN
IN HALF.
WHO KNEW THAT SHAKING HANDS WAS
SUCH A BAD THING.
I FELT IT.
I MEAN, I ALWAYS FELT IT.
AND YOU KNOW, I WAS NEVER TO A
POINT WHERE I CAN'T SHAKE
SOMEBODY'S HAND.
I KNEW PEOPLE LIKE THAT TOO.
THERE WEREN'T TOO MANY OF THEM.
BUT WHEN I RAN FOR OFFICE ALL OF
A SUDDEN I'M SHAKING HUNDREDS OF
HANDS AND IF I DIDN'T, I
WOULDN'T BE STANDING HERE.
I THINK THAT'S A CUSTOM THAT
MAYBE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO DO.
WE HAVE TO GET CLOSE TOGETHER.
WE HAVE TO SIT TOGETHER AT THE
STADIUMS.
WE HAVE TO SIT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER.
ALL THAT STUFF IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
I THINK THE CONCEPT OF SHAKING
HANDS MAINE IS SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING OF -- MAYBE IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE BIT
FROM THE PAST.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO DO TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY, IS THERE SOMETHING --
WE SEE PEOPLE CLAPPING WHEN
NURSES LEAVE.
>> WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF THAT.
YOU MIGHT SAY SOMETHING -- I
HAVE SEEN SUCH SUPPORT.
I SAW THIS MORNING WHERE
EVERYBODY'S CLAPPING FOR THE
FIRE DEPARTMENT, CLAPPING FOR
THE POLICEMEN.
THESE PEOPLE ARE -- YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE LIKE?
THEY'RE LIKE WARRIORS.
THEY'RE GOING INTO ELMHURST
HOSPITAL WHICH HAS BEEN TRAGIC,
RIGHT NEAR WHERE I GREW UP IN
QUEENS.
GOING IN AND THE PEOPLE IN
BUILDINGS, THEY'RE GOING -- I
MEAN, THEY'RE THE ROCK STARS.
THEY'RE WARRIORS.
NURSES, DOCTORS, FIRST
RESPONDERS, WHAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH, AND THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
THEY GO IN, AND BY THE WAY, EVEN
IF THEY HAVE GREAT EQUIPMENT
THEY'RE CATCHING IT.
YOU KNOW, GREAT EQUIPMENT.
THEY HAVE GOOD EQUIPMENT, THEY
CATCH IT.
THEY CATCH IT WITH GOOD, WITH
BAD.
IT IS EVIL.
TONY, YOU MIGHT SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT THAT.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
PEOPLE CAN REALLY FULLY
APPRECIATE THE EXTRAORDINARY
EFFORT OF THESE PEOPLE.
IT'S AMAZING.
I DID ALL OF MY MEDICAL TRAINING
IN NEW YORK CITY IN A BIG, BUSY
NEW YORK CITY HOSPITAL.
AT A TIME WHEN IT WAS JUST WHAT
YOU NORMALLY SEE IN A HOSPITAL.
I CAME TO NIH AND I SPENT ABOUT
FIVE TO EIGHT YEARS IN THE VERY
EARLY YEARS OF THE AIDS EPIDEMIC
WHICH WAS JUST THE DARKEST YEARS
OF MY LIFE BECAUSE ALMOST EVERY
ONE OF MY PATIENTS DIED BUT AS
WE KNEW THERE WAS VERY LITTLE
RISK OF GETTING INFECTED FROM A
PATIENT, TO SEE NOW WHAT THESE
BRAVE WARRIORS ARE DOING IN THE
HOSPITALS, NOT ONLY GIVING
LIFE-SAVING TREATMENT TO PEOPLE,
BUT EVERY SINGLE DAY PUTTING
THEMSELVES AT RISK FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY, I
JUST THINK THAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC OWE A PHENOMENAL DEBT OF
GRATITUDE FOR THESE PEOPLE.
AND THEY SHOULD JUST SALUTE THEM
AT EVERY WAY THEY CAN.
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE WERE AT WAR AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ, WHEN
YOU'RE AT AN AIRPORT AND YOU
WOULD SEE SOMEBODY WITH A
UNIFORM COME BY, EVERYBODY WOULD
DO THAT, I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD DO WHEN WE SEE A HEALTH
CARE WORKER, JUST APPLAUD THEM.
>> PRETTY MUCH WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
MIKE?
>> THE STORIES ARE INCREDIBLE
MOVING ABOUT WHAT HEALTH CARE
WORKERS ARE DOING EVERY DAY.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT THEY'RE GOING
BACK INTO THE HOSPITAL, IN
PLACES LIKE NEW YORK AND NEW
JERSEY, EARLIER THAN THAT IN
WASHINGTON STATE AND CALIFORNIA
WHERE THIS FIRST BEGAN.
IT'S NOT JUST THEY'RE PROVIDING
CARE TO PEOPLE.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF HOW
CONTAGIOUS THE CORONAVIRUS IS,
THEY'RE ALSO SUPPLEMENTING FOR
FAMILY.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT GETS TO ME.
WHEN I HEAR THE STORIES THAT
UNDERSTANDABLY IN NURSING HOMES
AND IN HOSPITALS THEY'RE
RESTRICTING VISITORS AND THEY
SHOULD.
TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS, TO BE BROUGHT INTO THE
HOSPITAL OR TO BE BROUGHT OUT.
AND SO TO HEAR THE STORIES OF
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WHO ARE
HOLDING UP AN iPHONE WHILE
SOMEONE WHO IS CRITICALLY ILL
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS MAY WELL BE
SAYING THEIR LAST GOOD-BYES TO
THEIR FAMILY, AND THEN TO BE
THERE IN THOSE MOMENTS, I MEAN,
OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE --
THEY'RE NOT JUST DOCTORS AND
NURSES TODAY.
THEY'RE SUPPLEMENTING FOR
FAMILY.
FOR PEOPLE ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AND I JUST THINK TOMORROW'S PALM
SUNDAY, IT'S HOLY WEEK AND GREAT
CHRISTIAN TRADITION AND I HAVE
PEOPLE ASK ME FROM TIME TO TIME,
SEND ME AN E-MAIL OR ON THE MANY
CONFERENCE CALLS THAT WE HAVE,
THEY SAY WHAT CAN WE BE PRAYING
ABOUT.
MY FIRST THOUGHT IS WITH
FAMILIES WHO LOST LOVED ONES AND
THE PATIENTS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
WITH CORONAVIRUS.
BUT DURING THIS VERY SPECIAL
WEEK, I JUST ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
PRAY FOR OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS.
PRAY FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THEY ARE REALLY THE HANDS AND
FEET EVERY DAY, NOT JUST OF
HEALTH CARE, BUT OF THE HEART OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WE ARE
ALL GRATEFUL FOR THEM EVERY HOUR
OF THE DAY.
>> AND THINK ALSO ABOUT THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT,
DEPENDING ON WHERE THEY ARE AND
WHERE THEY'RE WORKING BUT THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS,
THROWING UP A HOSPITAL IN NEW
YORK CITY, 2,500 BEDS IN THREE
DAYS.
I MEAN, THINK OF THAT.
AND FEMA, WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND THE NATIONAL GUARD IS NOW
DELIVERING FOR THE STATES
BECAUSE THE STATES WERE UNABLE
TO GET -- WE DROP IT AT A BIG
WAREHOUSE WHERE WE'RE TOLD TO
DROP IT.
AND SOME OF THE STATES WERE
UNABLE TO BRING IT FROM THE
WAREHOUSE TO THE SITE.
SO WE GOT THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
BECOME A DELIVERY SERVICE IF YOU
CAN BELIEVE IT AND THEY WOULD
BRING IT AND SOME OF THOSE SITES
WERE DANGEROUS SITES.
THEY WERE VERY DANGEROUS SITES.
THINK OF THAT.
IT'S BEEN AMAZING.
I JUST THINK I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE IT.
I'M SO PROUD OF THIS COUNTRY.
AND REALLY, IT'S A WORLD
PROBLEM.
SOME COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD ARE
JUST HANDLING IT SO WELL.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I KEEP SAYING
THIS, 151, THAT WAS AS OF TWO,
THREE DAYS AGO, IT'S PROBABLY
MORE.
SOME DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS THAT
MANY COUNTRIES, THAT'S HOW BIG
WAS.
MIKE SAID SOMETHING ELSE, PALM
SUNDAY, TOMORROW.
THINK OF IT, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
CHURCH ON PALM SUNDAY.
THINK OF NEXT SUNDAY, EASTER.
AND I BROUGHT IT UP BEFORE.
I SAID MAYBE WE COULD ALLOW
SPECIAL FOR CHURCHES, MAYBE WE
COULD TALK ABOUT IT, MAYBE WE
COULD ALLOW THEM WITH GREAT
SEPARATION OUTSIDE ON EASTER
SUNDAY.
I DON'T KNOW, IT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD TALK ABOUT.
BUT SOMEBODY DID SAY THAT, WELL
THEN YOU'RE SORT OF OPENING IT
UP TO THAT LITTLE -- YOU KNOW,
DO WE WANT TO TAKE A CHANCE ON
DOING THAT WHEN WE'VE BEEN DOING
SO WELL.
BUT EASTER SUNDAY, PALM SUNDAY,
I'M GOING TO BE WATCHING
TOMORROW LIVE FROM RIVERSIDE,
CALIFORNIA, GREAT CHURCH.
BUT I'M GOING TO BE WATCHING ON
A COMPUTER.
RIGHT.
ON A LAPTOP.
I THINK ON EASTER MAYBE I'LL BE
WATCHING FROM A LAPTOP AS
OPPOSED -- SO HOW SAD IS IT THAT
WE HAVE EASTER PALM AND EASTER
SUNDAY AND PEOPLE ARE WATCHING
ON LAPTOPS AND COMPUTERS.
IT'S SAD.
BUT THE JOB THAT THIS WHOLE
COUNTRY HAS DONE IS AMAZING.
BUT I'LL SAY THIS.
OUR MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS, WHAT
THEY'VE DONE, BECAUSE THEY ARE
-- THEY WALK INTO THOSE
HOSPITALS, YOU SEE THEM PUTTING
ON THEIR GEAR AND THEY'RE
PUTTING IT ON AS THEY'RE WALKING
THROUGH THE FRONT DOORS AND SOME
OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
DIE.
THEY'RE GOING TO DIE.
YOU KNOW.
IT'S LIKE INCREDIBLE.
AND WE CAN SAY WHAT WE WANT.
TONY AND DEB ABOUT YOUNG AND
MEDIUM AGED AND-PLENTY OF THOSE
PEOPLE DYING TOO.
IT GENERALLY HITS THE OLDER
PEOPLE WHERE THEY HAVE PROBLEMS.
IT HITS YOUNG AND MIDDLE AGED
PEOPLE TOO.
THESE PEOPLE ARE WALKING INTO
HOSPITALS THAT I WATCH.
I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLE AND
THEY'RE PUTTING THEIR OUTFIT,
AND THEY'RE GOING IN, AND IT'S
LIKE A -- THAT IS LIKE A WAR.
AGAIN, THERE'S NEVER BEEN
ANYTHING SO CONTAGIOUS AS THIS.
IN 1917, IT WAS VICIOUS, IF YOU
GOT IT, BUT IT WASN'T CONTAGIOUS
LIKE THIS.
NOW, IN 1917, HAD THEY THE
INTERNET AND ALL THE MEANS OF
COMMUNICATION THEY COULD HAVE
PRACTICED DISTANCING.
BY THE TIME PEOPLE STARTED
THINKING IN THOSE TERMS, THEY
LOST I GUESS 75 TO 100 MILLION
PEOPLE.
SO THAT'S MODERN -- THAT'S A
MODERN DAY GREAT THING THAT
HAPPENED.
PLEASE.
>> WHAT SENSE DO YOU THINK YOU
CAN USE ANTIBODY TESTS TO
DETERMINE WHO CAN GO BACK TO
WORK?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I WOULD RATHER LEAVE THAT TO THE
DOCTOR.
DOCTOR, DO YOU HAVE AN ANSWER TO
THAT?
>> WE THINK IT WILL BE A TOOL TO
HELP US GET PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
IT WILL BE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW, IF YOU HAVE
AN ANTIBODY THAT MEANS YOU WERE
EXPOSED AND HAVE RECOVERED FROM
IT.
THAT WITH THE INFORMATION ABOUT
DIAGNOSIS SHOULD HELP.
>> HOW QUICKLY CAN WE SCALE UP
THIS TESTING TO DETERMINE ON A
LARGE SCALE HOW MANY PEOPLE CAN
GO BACK TO WORK?
>> AS YOU KNOW, COUPLE WEEKS AGO
WE PROVIDED A GREAT DEAL OF
REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY AROUND
THIS.
A LOT OF GREAT DEVELOPERS HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS, DR. BIRX
PUT A CALL OUT TO ACADEMIC LABS
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO DO THIS
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH A NUMBER OF
MANUFACTURERS SO WE THINK THAT
IT CAN BE SCALED UP RELATIVELY
QUICKLY.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, A QUESTION FOR
DR. FAUCI.
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW YOU HAD
SAID THAT YOU KNEW THE 15-DAY
GUIDANCE WOULD NOT BE ENOUGH.
I WANTED TO ASK YOUR CONFIDENCE
LEVEL ABOUT THE 30-DAY GUIDANCE
AND WHETHER IT WILL BE ENOUGH.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S TOUGH TO TALK
ABOUT LEVELS OF CONFIDENCE BUT I
CAN TELL YOU ONE THING THAT I
FEEL STRONGLY, THAT IF WE DO IN
A VERY PROACTIVE WAY WHAT I SAID
IN MY OPENING COMMENTS AND
PEOPLE LITERALLY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS A BASELINE HAVE THAT
PHYSICAL SEPARATION AND AS WE
MENTIONED UP HERE, THERE WILL BE
VAIR I DID -- VARYING DEGREES OF
THAT.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE DOING SOME
DEGREE OF THIS PHYSICAL
SEPARATION.
IF WE DO THAT, AGAIN, I HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT WHAT WE WILL SEE
IS THE TURNING AROUND OF THE
CURVE.
WHETHER OR NOT IT WILL BE ALL
THE WAY DOWN WHERE WE WANT, IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO SAY.
I WOULD BE FOOLISH TO SAY THAT.
BUT THE ONE THING I AM CONFIDENT
IN, SO LET'S TAKE THIS TO THE
BANK, THAT MITIGATION WORKS.
SO IT DOES.
WE'VE SEEN IT IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WE'VE SEEN IT IN OUR OWN
COUNTRY.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY I KEEP
COMING UP AT EVERY CHANCE I GET
TO PLEA WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TO PLEASE TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
GUIDELINES THAT THE VICE
PRESIDENT KEEPS PUTTING UP WITH
HIS CHART BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE POINTS HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH PHYSICAL
SEPARATION.
>> IT DOES WORK.
BUT AGAIN, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
DESTROY OUR COUNTRY.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW, AT A CERTAIN
POINT YOU'LL LOSE MORE PEOPLE
THIS WAY THROUGH ALL OF THE
PROBLEMS CAUSED THAN YOU WILL
WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW I
THINK IS GOING TO BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T KNOW.
WE HAVE A BIG DECISION TO MAKE
AT A CERTAIN POINT.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A BIG DECISION TO MAKE.
WE WENT THIS EXTRA PERIOD OF
TIME.
BUT I SAID IT FROM THE
BEGINNING, THE CURE CANNOT BE
WORSE THAN THE PROBLEM ITSELF.
AND WE CANNOT LET THAT HAPPEN.
WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLE COUNTRY.
WE WERE HAVING THE GREATEST
PERIOD IN OUR COUNTRY'S HISTORY
FROM AN ECONOMIC STANDPOINT AND
MANY OTHER WAYS.
WE CANNOT LET THIS CONTINUE.
SO AT A CERTAIN POINT SOME HARD
DECISIONS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
BE MADE.
GO AHEAD.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, VENTILATOR
MANUFACTURERS ARE DOUBLING, TRIP
-- TRIPLING PRODUCTION.
SOME ARE PREDICTING THERE WILL
STILL BE SHORTAGES OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF VENTILATORS.
IS IT TIME FOR YOU TO LEVEL WITH
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT THERE
LIKELY WILL BE SHORTAGES OF
VENTILATORS IN SOME CASES?
>> COULD BE.
I MEAN, IT COULD BE YOU HAVE
SHORTAGES AND IT COULD ALSO BE
THAT YOU HAVE SOME THAT HAVE WAY
OVER-ESTIMATED THE NUMBER OF
VENTILATORS THEY NEED.
WE THINK THAT -- WE HAVE A GOOD
AMOUNT READY TO MOVE.
I MEAN, LITERALLY LIKE AN ARMY.
THEY'RE READY TO MOVE TO ANY HOT
SPOT.
SOME OF THE ONES YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- ALWAYS A NASTY QUESTION
FROM CNN.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW REMARKS YOU'VE
ASKED THAT QUESTION ABOUT 10
TIMES OVER THE COURSE OF A
MONTH.
LOOK, WE'RE MOBILEIZED AND READY
TO GO.
WE HAVE A LOT OF VENTILATORS
READY TO GO.
AND IF WE HAD GIVEN THEM ALL
OUT, WE WOULDN'T.
AND YOU WOULD BE OVER-STOCKED IN
MANY AREAS.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE HAVE A
VERY GOOD PLAN TO TAKE FROM SOME
AREAS, EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE THE
TEN OR ALMOST THE 10,000, WE'RE
ALSO TAKING FROM AREAS THAT
WON'T BE AS BADLY HIT AS TODAY
WE THINK THEY WILL BE.
THERE WILL BE SOME AREAS HIT
HARDER THAN WE THINK AND THERE'S
NOTHING THAT DEBORAH OR TONY OR
ANY OF THESE PROFESSIONALS CAN
DO ABOUT IT.
THIS THING MOVES IN A LOT OF
WAYS.
BUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE -- AND YOU
LOOK AT US COMPARED TO A LOT OF
OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE'RE IN MUCH BETTER SHAPE.
BUT THESE PROFESSIONALS HAVE
DONE AN AMAZING JOB.
NOW, OVER THE NEXT WEEK AND TWO
WEEKS -- THIS IS GOING TO BE A
VERY, VERY DEADLY PERIOD,
UNFORTUNATELY.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT SO
THAT WE LOSE AS FEW LIVES AS
POSSIBLE AND I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
I THINK WE ALREADY ARE
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT REGARD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT GRAPH AND
YOU SEE ALL OF THE BUMPS IF YOU
WANT TO CALL IT AT A VERY LOW
LEVEL AND YOU SEE A COUPLE OF
THE HIGHER LEVELS, THEY WERE
TOUGH.
BUT YOU SEE ALL OF THOSE LEVELS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU LOOK AT, WHEN
YOU HEAR ABOUT ITALY AND YOU
HEAR ABOUT FRANCE AND -- WHAT WE
HAVE IS WE HAVE MANY ITALYS ALL
OVER.
THEY'RE LIKE COUNTRIES,
CALIFORNIA IS A COUNTRY, NEW
YORK IS A COUNTRY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THEM FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
WE HAVE MANY LIKE COUNTRY SPOTS.
SOME ARE HOT SPOTS AND THERE'S
NOTHING WE'RE GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST SURPRISES IS
LOUISIANA.
BECAUSE IT STARREDDED OFF SO
GOOD AND -- STARTED OFF SO GOOD
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IT SHOT UP
LIKE A ROCKET.
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO HAVE
VENTILATORS WHEREVER WE POSSIBLY
CAN.
>> THE EFFORTS OF SOME
COMPANIES TO RAMP UP PRODUCTION,
IT STILL WON'T BE ENOUGH.
>> NEW YORK WANTED 40,000
VENTILATORS.
OKAY.
40,000.
THINK OF WHAT 40,000 IS.
IT'S LIKE CARS.
IT'S A BIG PROJECT.
IT'S AN EXPENSIVE PRODUCT.
SOME OF THEM ARE $50,000 APIECE.
I SAW ONE THE OTHER DAY,
$55,000.
THAT WAS BEFORE THEY START
PLAYING THE GAMES WITH SUPPLY
AND DEMAND.
OKAY.
SOME ARE VERY, VERY WE CALL THEM
LUXURY, SOME ARE NOT.
BUT FRANKLY, THESE ARE VERY
EXPENSIVE PRODUCTS.
THESE ARE VERY HIGH TECH
PROJECTS AND PRODUCTS AND THEY
TAKE A PERIOD OF TIME.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF THEM BEING
BUILT RIGHT NOW.
SOME WILL BE READY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EXTRA
AND WE'LL KEEP THEM AT
HOSPITALS.
BUT A LOT OF HOSPITALS, A LOT OF
STATES HAD THE CHANCE OF THE
GETTING VENTILATORS AND THEY
TURNED THOSE VENTILATORS DOWN SO
THEY COULD SPEND MONEY ON
SOMETHING ELSE AND IN A WAY I
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE WHO
THINKS A THING LIKE THIS -- IT'S
NOT A -- IF I'M TOLD LIKE
PERHAPS NEW YORK, YOU CAN SPENDS
$1 BILLION ON VENTILATORS AND
GET 16,000 OR A MASSIVE NUMBER
OF VENTILATORS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
OFFERED OVER THE YEARS, OR YOU
CAN BUILD A NEW BRIDGE OR ROAD
OR SOMETHING.
I MEAN, I UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
WORKS.
I'M NOT BLAMING ANYBODY.
I'M JUST SAYING A LOT OF THE
STATES HAD CHANCES OF
STOCKPILING A LOT OF
VENTILATORS.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT.
AND I THINK WE'RE DOING A VERY
GOOD JOB IN HELPING THEM OUT.
PLEASE, YES.
AND IT'S A VERY FAIR QUESTION.
I UNDERSTAND THAT QUESTION VERY
WELL.
>> A FOLLOW-UP ON WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN SAYING ABOUT IT BEING A
DEADLY WEEK OR FEW COMING.
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OR
PERHAPS DR. BIRX WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR AMERICA, PLEASE.
>> I'D LIKE TO ASK ALSO -- I'D
LIKE TO SAY WE KNOW PRETTY MUCH
THE LINE OF ATTACK.
WE KNOW THE NUMBERS, THE NUMBERS
ARE THE NUMBERS.
THEY SEEM TO BE CHECKING OUT
UNFORTUNATELY OR -- IN SOME
CASES THEY'RE ON THE LOW SIDE
WHICH WE'RE VERY HAPPY.
WE WANT TO KEEP THEM ON THE VERY
LOW SIDE AND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
HEADED AND I THINK THAT'S MAYBE
WHERE WE'RE HEADED.
I'D LIKE TO ASK MAYBE YOU AND
TONY WHAT -- WHERE IS THE WEAK
OR THE NUMBER OF DAYS OF
GREATEST ATTACK, WHAT WILL BE
OUR WORST DAY?
IF THAT'S POSSIBLE TO DETERMINE.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING, RIGHT?
>> HOW MANY DEATHS EXACTLY ARE
YOU EXPECTING?
>> SO, AS YOU CAN LOOK IN THE
PLACES THAT ARE THE MOST
DIFFICULT HIT RIGHT NOW, THE
DETROIT AREA, THE NEW YORK AREA,
LOUISIANA AREA AND WE ARE DOING
IT BY THE COUNTIES IN THOSE
STATES, BECAUSE THERE ARE --
MOSTLY IT'S METRO AREAS AND THE
BEDROOM COMMUNITIES AROUND THOSE
METRO AREAS BECAUSE PEOPLE WENT
TO WORK AND GOT EXPOSED AND CAME
HOME AND EXPOSED OTHERS.
IF YOU LOOK IN NEW YORK, YOU SEE
THAT IT'S IN LONG ISLAND,
ANDNASSAU COUNTY.
ALL OF THOSE COUNTIES, WAYNE AND
OAKLAND, THEY'RE ALL ON THE
UP-SIDE OF THEIR CURVE OF
MORTALITIES.
SO YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GET TO THE
PEAK, YOU COME DOWN THE OTHER
SIDE.
>> WHEN WILL THAT PEAK BE?
>> BY THE PREDICTIONS THAT ARE
IN THAT HEALTHDATA.ORG, THEY'RE
PREDICTING IN THOSE THREE HOT
SPOTS, ALL OF THEM HITTING
TOGETHER IN THE NEXT SIX TO
SEVEN DAYS.
>> TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DEATHS
IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME?
>> YOU CAN GO TO THE WEBSITE.
IT'S VARIABLE.
EACH ONE OF THOSE COMMUNITIES IS
DIFFERENT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHERE NEW YORK IS,
HOW MUCH THEIR MORTALITY HAS
BEEN AND YOU KNOW -- WHAT WE'RE
SEEING TODAY ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE INFECTED TWO OR THREE WEEKS
AGO.
IF MITIGATION IN NEW YORK WORKED
AND WE BELIEVE IT IS WORKING,
THE CASES ARE GOING TO START TO
GO DOWN BUT THE MORTALITY WILL
BE A LAG BEHIND THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE CO-MORBIDITIES
AND OTHER CONDITIONS.
SO THAT'S WHY ALL OF THE
PREDICTIONS ARE THAT THIS NEXT
WEEK -- AND I THINK WE SAID THIS
LAST SUNDAY WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THE CHARTS, AND IT'S DIFFICULT
AND WE TRIED TO PREPARE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT, YOU HAVE TO -- AS MUCH AS
YOU GO UP, YOU HAVE TO COME DOWN
THE OTHER SIDE BECAUSE COMING
DOWN IS A REFLECTION OF THE CASE
THAT'S WERE COMING IN BEFORE.
>> WOULD YOU RATHER NOT SAY A
NUMBER.
>> I'D RATHER NOT SAY A NUMBER
BUT THE NUMBERS ARE AVAILABLE IF
YOU GO TO THE WEBSITE.
YOU CAN SEE THERE'S SEVERAL
HUNDREDS PER DAY IN NEW YORK.
AND I THINK GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS
TALKED ABOUT THAT INCREASING
STILL INTO THE FIVE, SIX, 700
RANGE A DAY.
SO THAT'S VERY CONCERNING TO US.
WE, AGAIN, APPLAUD THE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS WHO ARE DOING EVERY
SINGLE THING HUMANLY POSSIBLE TO
SAVE MORE LIVES AND WE ARE
ENSURING ON A VENTILATOR BY
VENTILATOR, DAY BY DAY TO GET
THEM THERE SO THAT WE CAN SAY
AND WE CAN BE THERE WHEN THEY
NEED IT.
BECAUSE WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
THAT GROUP THAT COMES IN AFTER
ALL OTHER RESOURCES ARE
EXHAUSTED AND WE REALLY APPLAUD
WHAT OREGON DID AND WE REALLY
APPLAUD WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS
DOING ABOUT MOVING BETWEEN THE
STATES, BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
COUNTIES TO BRING THEM TO NEW
YORK.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT'S NEEDED
TODAY.
A DIFFERENT PLACE WILL BE NEEDED
TOMORROW.
>> A FOLLOW-UP ON SOMETHING YOU
SAID YESTERDAY THAT YOU HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT PENNSYLVANIA,
COLORADO AND WASHINGTON, D.C.
COULD YOU EXPAND ON THAT?
>> WE'RE WATCHING THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE STARTING TO GO ON THAT
UPSIDE OF THE CURVE.
WE'RE HOPING AND BELIEVING THAT
IF PEOPLE MITIGATE STRONGLY THE
WORK THAT THEY DID OVER THE LAST
TWO WEEKS WILL BLUNT THAT CURVE
AND THEY WON'T HAVE THE SAME
UPWARD SLOPE AND PEAK THAT NEW
YORK, NEW JERSEY, CONNECTICUT
AND PART OF RHODE ISLAND ARE
HAVING.
SO THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT --
THE NEXT TWO WEEKS ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT.
THAT'S WHY YOU'VE HEARD FROM DRE
PRESIDENT AND THE VICE PRESIDENT
THAT THIS IS THE MOMENT TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT YOU CAN ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL GUIDELINES.
THIS IS THE MOMENT TO NOT BE
GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE, NOT
GOING TO THE PHARMACY, BUT DOING
EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO KEEP YOUR
FAMILY AND YOUR FRIENDS SAFE AND
THAT MEANS EVERYBODY DOING THE R
HANDS.
>> SO DITTO TO EVERYTHING THAT
DR. BIRX SAID BUT ALSO TO
EMPHASIZE WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO DO THAT, BECAUSE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THREE OR FOUR REALLY
KEY HOT SPOTS THAT ARE STILL
GOING UP.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT
THE ONES THAT ARE DOWN AT THAT
LOWER LEVEL THAT DR. BIRX SHOWED
THE OTHER DAY, THOSE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY'RE STILL GOING UP.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T
HAVE MULTIPLE WAVES OF PEAKS.
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION OF WHEN WE CAN
START PULLING BACK.
BECAUSE IF YOU KEEP HAVING
MULTIPLE PEAKS AND DIFFERENT
WAVES, THAT'S GOING TO MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT.
>>
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT I SAID JUST BEFORE AND I
KEEP REPEATING, JUST MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY DOES AT LEAST THE
MINIMAL AMOUNT OF THAT PHYSICAL
SEPARATION BECAUSE THE VIRUS HAS
NO PLACE TO GO IF YOU'RE
PHYSICALLY SEPARATED.
>> ONE OF THE REASONS THAT I
KEEP TALKING ABOUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE IS THAT THE
QUESTION THAT NOBODY EVER ASKS
AND THE QUESTION THAT I MOST
HATE THE ANSWER TO IS WHAT
HAPPENS IF YOU DO HAVE A
VENTILATOR, WHAT ARE YOUR
CHANCES?
AND I JUST HOPE THAT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WINS, COUPLED
WITH PERHAPS THE Z-PACK AS WE
CALL IT, DEPENDENT TOTALLY ON
YOUR DOCTORS AND THE DOCTORS
THERE, BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
IF YOU DO HAVE THE VENTILATOR,
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION.
AND I HATE GIVING THE ANSWER.
SO I DON'T WANT TO GET THEM
THERE.
I DON'T WANT TO GET THEM THERE.
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY, A
POSSIBILITY, AND I SAY IT, WHAT
DO HAVE YOU TO LOSE.
I'LL SAY IT AGAIN.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
TAKE IT.
I REALLY THINK THEY SHOULD TAKE
IT.
BUT IT'S THEIR CHOICE AND IT'S
THE DOCTOR'S CHOICE OR THE
DOCTOR'S IN THE HOSPITAL BUT
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, TRY IT.
IF YOU'D LIKE.
THE OTHER THING, IF YOU HAVE A
HEART CONDITION I UNDERSTAND,
PROBABLY YOU STAY AWAY FROM THE
Z-PACK.
BUT THAT'S AN ANTIBIOTIC.
IT CAN CLEAN OUT THE LUNGS.
THE LUNGS ARE A POINT OF ATTACK
FOR THIS HORRIBLE VIRUS.
BUT WHEN HAVE YOU A VENTILATOR,
DON'T ASK THE ANSWER BECAUSE I
HATE IT.
IF YOU HAVE IT, AND IT'S WORKING
BEAUTIFULLY, I DON'T LIKE THE
ANSWER BECAUSE IT'S NOT A VERY
HIGH PERCENTAGE.
SO I WANT TO KEEP THEM OUT OF
VENTILATORS.
I WANT TO KEEP THEM -- IF THE
DRUG WORKS, IT WILL BE -- NOT A
GAME-CHANGER BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
A NICE ENOUGH TERM.
IT WILL BE WONDERFUL.
IT WILL BE SO BEAUTIFUL.
IT WILL BE A GIFT FROM HEAVEN IF
IT WORKS BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE GO
INTO THOSE VENTILATORS, YOU KNOW
THE ANSWERS, I KNOW THE ANSWERS
AND I'M GLAD YOU DON'T WRITE
ABOUT IT.
MIKE, PLEASE.
>> YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
EXPERTS WHAT OUR TASK FORCE HAS
HEARD.
IT'S GOING TO BE A DIFFICULT
WEEK FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU WILL SEE TESTING INCREASED
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND SO CASES
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO RISE.
ACROSS AMERICA AND BEFORE I GIVE
A FEW FACTS RELEVANT TO AN
EARLIER QUESTION ABOUT
VENTILATORS, LET ME JUST -- LET
ME ADD MY VOICE TO WHAT THE
PRESIDENT JUST SAID AND WHAT ALL
THE PHYSICIANS WHO HAVE SPOKEN
HAVE SAID.
EVEN THOUGH WE SEE THE LOSSES
RISING IN THE DAYS AHEAD, DO NOT
BE DISCOURAGED.
BECAUSE THERE IS EVIDENCE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY THAT AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN PUTTING THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND MITIGATION INTO
PRACTICE AND IT IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
WE ARE SEEING IT IN THE NEW
CASES THAT ARE BEING REPORTED.
BECAUSE REMEMBER, PEOPLE --
FAMILIES WHO EXPERIENCE LOSS UP
TO THIS DAY AND IN THE NEXT WEEK
HAVE A LOVED ONE WHO CONTRACTED
THE CORONAVIRUS IN MOST CASES
MORE THAN TWO WEEKS AGO.
IN MANY CASES, BEFORE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND MITIGATION
EFFORTS WERE PUT INTO EFFECT.
AND SO WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU,
BELIEVE IN THE PRESIDENT'S
CORONAVIRUS GUIDELINES FOR
AMERICA.
GO TO CORONAVIRUS.GOV, PRINT
THEM OFF AGAIN, PUT THEM ON THE
REFRIGERATOR AND REMIND YOURSELF
TO PUT THEM INTO PRACTICE.
ON THE SUBJECT OF VENTILATORS,
IF I CAN AMPLIFY THE POINT THE
PRESIDENT MADE, OUR TEAM AT FEMA
IS DOING A REMARKABLE JOB
ROCKERRING WITH GOVERNORS, STATE
HEALTH OFFICIALS AND LOCAL
HOSPITALS, PARTICULARLY FOCUSED
ON OUR PRIORITY AREAS.
WE'LL REFER TO THE NEW YORK
METRO AREA.
WHICH INCLUDES NEW JERSEY AND
CONNECTICUT.
WE'RE FOCUSED ON THE NEW ORLEANS
METRO AREA, LOUISIANA.
WE'RE FOCUSING ON DETROIT, WE'RE
FOCUSING ON CHICAGO.
THESE ARE THE AREAS WHERE WE SEE
THE SIGNIFICANT RISE IN CASES.
AND WE ARE SURGING SUPPLIES
SPECIFICALLY VENTILATORS BUT ALL
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
FROM FEMA TO THOSE AREAS AND
JUST TO GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES, I SPOKE TO GOVERNORS
IN NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
LOUISIANA, MASSACHUSETTS,
MICHIGAN AND MARYLAND TODAY
ALONE AND IN THOSE CASES,
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS ACTUALLY
ASSESSING ALL OF THE AVAILABLE
VENTILATORS.
WE SENT 4,400 VENTILATORS
ALREADY TO NEW YORK.
AS HAS ALREADY BEEN REFERENCED,
THEY'RE GOING TO RECEIVE A
SHIPMENT OF OVER 1,000 FROM
OVERSAWS AND ALLOW ME TO SAY AS
I TOLD HER PERSONALLY TODAY, THE
GOVERNOR OF OREGON, GOVERNOR
KATE BROWN, HER UNILATERAL
DECISION TO SEND 140 VENTILATORS
BECAUSE OREGON -- THEY FELT
OREGON TODAY IS IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY COULD GIVE THOSE
VENTILATORS TO NEW YORK, TO ME
WAS IN THE VERY HIGHEST AMERICAN
TRADITION OF LOVING YOUR
NEIGHBOR.
AND WHEN I TALKED TO GOVERNOR
CUOMO, MR. PRESIDENT, HE
ACTUALLY TOLD ME THEY NEVER
ASKED OREGON FOR THE VENTILATORS
AND GOVERNOR BROWN HADN'T EVEN
CALLED HIM TO TELL HIM SHE WAS
DOING THAT.
IT REALLY IS REMARK A AND I
TALKED TO GOVERNOR HOGAN TODAY
AND THE PRESIDENT I WILL BE
SPEAKING TO ALL OF AMERICA'S
GOVERNORS ON MONDAY AGAIN, I
TOLD HIM HOW INSPIRED I WAS AND
HOW HE OUGHT TO SPREAD THE WORD
TO OTHER GOVERNORS IN AREAS
WHERE THEY CAN SPARE RESOURCES
TO BE JOINING WITH US AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND PROVIDING THEM
TO STATES AT THE POINT OF THE
NEED.
BUT JUST A FEW FOR INSTANCE AS
WE TRACK NEW JERSEY, AS I TOLD
GOVERNOR PHIL MURPHY, WE
DEPLOYED 1200 VENTILATORS TO --
200 VENTILATORS TO NEWER NEW JEY
TODAY.
LOUISIANA WE'RE MONITORING HOUR
BY HOUR WHAT'S TAKING PLACE IN
NEW ORLEANS WITH SOME
ENCOURAGING NEWS BUT STILL GREAT
CHALLENGES.
YESTERDAY, YOU HEARD THE
PRESIDENT SAY THAT WE DEPLOYED
330,000 GAL -- GOWNS THAT HAD
BEEN DELIVERED TO PUBLIC HEALTH
SYSTEMS THERE, 200 VENTILATORS.
I SPOKE TO GOVERNOR CHARLIE
BAKER TODAY, WAS ABLE TO INFORM
HIM WE'RE WATCHING BOSTON VERY
CLOSELY, 100 VENTILATORS ARE
DEPLOYING TODAY.
I SPOKE TO GOVERNOR GRETCHEN
WHITMER TODAY, DETROIT IS
EXPERIENCING A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF CASES.
WE'RE WATCHING IT CAREFULLY.
AND TODAY, FEMA DIRECTED 300 OF
VENTILATORS TO MICHIGAN.
AGAIN, AS THE PRESIDENT SAID,
WE'RE ALL WORKING OUR HEARTS
OUT.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO SAY TO
AMERICAN FAMILIES AND WHAT I
WANT TO SAY TO HEALTH CARE
WORKERS IS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
IDENTIFY THE RESOURCES, LEAVE NO
STONE UNTURNED AND WE ARE GOING
TO FOCUS RESOURCES ON THOSE
AREAS IN THE ORDER THAT THEY
EMERGE.
NOW, THE LAST THOUGHT IS BACK ON
MITIGATION, WE ARE HOPING THAT
WE DO NOT SEE OTHER MAJOR CITIES
IN THE COUNTRY EXPERIENCE WHAT
SEATTLE EXPERIENCED, WHAT
GREATER NEW YORK CITY AREA IS
EXPERIENCING, WHAT NEW ORLEANS
IS EXPERIENCING AND THAT'S ALL
IN THE HANDS OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TODAY.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE
-- CORONAVIRUS.GOV, PUT INTO
PRACTICE THE PRESIDENT'S
CORONAVIRUS GUIDELINES AND YOU
WILL DO YOUR PART TO SAVE LIVES,
PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND
ENSURE THAT WE WILL HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO MEET THIS MOMENT
WHEREVER THE NEED SHOULD ARISE.
>> MR. PRESIDENT --
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
-- LOAN PROGRAM GOT UP AND
RUNNING YESTERDAY.
WE HEARD FROM A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS, A LOT OF
CONCERN OF WHETHER THEY WILL GET
THE MONEY.
SOME SAY THE BANKS WEREN'T READY
TO START PROCESSING LOANS.
SOME BANKS ARE --
>> WE'RE WAY AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
THE BANKS ARE IN GREAT SHAPE.
JP MORGAN CHASE, BANK OF
AMERICA, THEY'RE SO FAR AHEAD
678 THIS IS TYPICAL WITH YOU IN
PARTICULAR.
THEY'RE NOT BEHIND.
IT'S BEEN A FLAWLESS -- IT'S
BEEN FLAWLESS SO FAR.
FAR BEYOND OUR EXPECTATIONS.
YOU SHOULD SAY I HEAR YOU'RE
DOING WELL BUT MAYBE -- I DON'T
EVEN HEAR OF ANY GLITCH.
THEY'VE DONE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF LOANS TO SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND THESE ARE GREAT LOANS.
THESE ARE LOANS THAT THEY GET
IMMEDIATELY PAID OFF.
THESE ARE LOANS THAT GET
BUSINESSES BACK.
I WISH YOU COULD ASK A QUESTION
WHERE SOMETHING'S WORKING SO
WELL -- MAYBE THINGS WON'T WORK
WELL AND I DON'T MIND THAT KIND
BUT WHEN SOMETHING'S WORKING SO
WELL AND YOU ASK A QUESTION IN
SUCH A NEGATIVE WAY.
IT'S DOING GREAT.
GO AHEAD.
DOING GREAT.
REALLY GOOD.
MAYBE IT WON'T IN TWO WEEKS AND
I'LL RESPOND DIFFERENTLY BUT
IT'S DOING GREAT.
YOU KNOW IT AND SO DOES EVERYONE
ELSE.
EVERYONE'S SHOCKED HOW WELL IT'S
DOING.
>> DR. BIRX MENTIONED SOME
DEMOGRAPHICS SUCH AS SEEING MEN
MIGHT BE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO THE
VIRUS, SEEING IN EUROPE MORE
CASES AMONG THE BETWEEN 30 AND
50.
HAS THE DATA THAT YOU'VE SEEN IN
THE PAST TWO WEEKS CHANGED THAT
ASSESSMENT?
ARE MEN MORE SUSCEPTIBLE?
>> IT HASN'T CHANGED MUCH HAS
IT.
>> THE SAME PATTERN.
>> SAME PATTERN.
SAME ANSWER THAT WE'VE GIVEN
YOU.
>> THAT INCLUDES FOLKS BETWEEN
30 AND 50 BEING MORE ADVERSELY
AFFECTED THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
ASIA?
>> NO, TOMORROW I'LL BRING YOU
ALL THE GRAPHS BACK.
>> WE CAN BRING AN UPDATED
GRAPH BUT IT'S VERY SIMILAR.
PLEASE.
>> TALKED ABOUT POSSIBLY
RESTRICTING FLIGHTS FROM HOT
SPOTS.
WHERE ARE YOU ON THAT?
>> WE'RE LOOKING AT IT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE DEALING WITH
GOVERNORS, WE'RE DEALING WITH
AIRLINES.
WE'RE DEALING WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT DECISION.
WE'RE ALSO DOING TESTING GETTING
INTO PLANES, VERY STRONG
TESTING.
STATES ARE DOING TESTING OF
PEOPLE THAT LEAVE PLANES.
THEY DON'T WANT PEOPLE COMING IN
WHO ARE INFECTED.
UNDERSTANDING THAT AND THE LEVEL
OF TESTING HAS BEEN ENORMOUS,
OKAY.
AND SOME STATES ARE SAYING YOU
HAVE TO GO IN QUARANTINE FOR TWO
WEEKS IF YOU COME FROM CERTAIN
AREAS.
SO KNOWING THAT, WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNORS.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, WHAT KIND OF
TEST -- YOU MEAN DOMESTIC
TRAVEL?
>> SOME STATES ARE DOING WHEN
THEY LAND, THEY'RE DOING STRONG,
POWERFUL TESTING.
GO AHEAD.
>>
[ INDISCERNIBLE ]
>> YOU'LL CHECK UP AGAIN.
>> A QUESTION ON VENTILATORS --
>> GOVERNMENTS ARE DOING IT TOO.
>> THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK
SAID HE RECEIVED VENTILATORS
FROM ALIBABA WHICH I THINK IS
YOUR FRIEND.
WOULD YOU CALL ON THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO DONATE VENTILATORS,
NOT NECESSARILY FROM EUROPE BUT
OTHER STATES LIKE LOUISIANA.
>> JACK IS A FRIEND OF MINE AND
HE'S MADE IT VERY POSSIBLE TO
GET ABOUT 1,000 VENTILATORS FROM
CHINA.
BUT THAT WAS FROM HIM AND MY
OTHER FRIEND.
THAT WAS REALLY A GIFT AND WE
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
IT WAS VERY NICE OF THEM.
I THINK WE'VE HAD ENOUGH.
WE'LL BE SEEING YOU VERY SOON.
AND I'M SURE THAT YOU KNOW THAT
ALL OF US ARE GOING TO BE
WORKING VERY HARD.
WE'RE WORKING VERY HARD.
WE ARE COMING UP TO A TIME
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
HORRENDOUS, PROBABLY A TIME LIKE
WE HAVEN'T SEEN IN THIS COUNTRY,
WOULDN'T YOU SAY.
I DON'T THINK WE'VE SEEN A TIME
LIKE THIS IN THE COUNTRY.
WE'RE GETTING TO THAT POINT
WHERE IT'S GOING TO REALLY BE
SOME VERY BAD NUMBERS.
WE WANT TO KEEP THOSE NUMBERS A
LOT LOWER THAN THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN AND WE WILL DO THAT.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS TALENT
WORKING, WE HAVE TREMENDOUS
PEOPLE AND THAT INCLUDES
GOVERNORS, THAT INCLUDES
EVERYBODY.
EVERYBODY'S WORKING.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE GETTING
TO THAT TIME WHEN THE NUMBERS
ARE GOING TO PEAK AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE A GOOD LOOKING
SITUATION.
I REALLY BELIEVE WE PROBABLY
HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THESE KIND OF NUMBERS, MAYBE
DURING THE WAR, A WORLD WAR, A
WORLD WAR I OR II OR SOMETHING
BUT THIS IS A WAR, ALL TO ITSELF
AND IT'S A TERRIBLE THING.
WE WILL BE SEEING YOU SOON.
WE'LL KEEP YOU TOTALLY ABREAST.
WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE RELEASING
NEW VENTILATOR NUMBERS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LOT OF THEM COMING AND
A LOT OF THEM GOING TO DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS AND WE APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANK
ERIC: AND AMERICANS WHO ARE
STAYING HOME, THAT WAS THE WHITE
HOUSE BRIEFING.
I'M ERIC SHAWN.
THAT'S THE LATEST FROM THIS FOX
STATION.
PLEASE STAY TUNED TO TO FOX NEWS
CHANNEL FOR THE VERY LATEST.
WE NOW REJOIN THE FOX NEWS
CHANNEL.
THE PRESIDENT, ARTHEL, SAID THIS
IS A VERYOU